We,
and we're back ladies,
gentlemen,
two in a day.
That's how we roll.
Um,
and this episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
If you go to legal zoom,
you my friend,
you fellow Americans just got done celebrating independence day,
feeling all star Stripey bantery and
what does America about folks,
it's about fucking innovation and shit coming up with your own thing,
getting your freak on,
getting it together,
planning for the future.
I don't know if it's about that.
It's kind of just about living in America,
right?
Although other stuff sounds good though.
It's motivational speaking.
It's like you're a fucking titan and if you're going to the school and you were
tight and you'll be like a titan,
um,
anyway,
uh,
one of the best things that you could do that for your own personal sense of
satisfaction or growth or just independence is to be a person has their own
business.
Um,
if you've ever thought about doing that,
you can do that.
You can start a corporation.
You do do all the necessary legal steps online using legal zoom quite easily.
If you have some sort of an invention that you want to patent that you want to
lock down.
If you have some sort of a thing that you want to have become your business,
legal zoom can help you with that.
They can set it all up and they can do it for less than,
well,
I think the the lowest for the,
for setting an LLC is as little as 99 bucks.
You can get a a will,
he could set up,
you can even get divorced if you're,
if you're married to someone.
Cool.
Look at that 99 bucks to form an LLC.
It starts at nine,
nine bucks.
No waiting in line.
Everything done naked,
everything done drunk as fuck.
He looks happy with it and the guy,
that guy's happy as fuck with everything,
but his haircut,
his hair,
his hair is strange.
It's a strange guy.
But Hey,
I don't have any hair,
so who am I talking?
Shit.
Anyway,
um,
for over,
you know,
for a long time legal zoom has been doing,
helping America's get personalized wills,
powers of attorney,
a living trusts,
and they helped protect your assets.
S corporations,
LLCs,
trademarks,
real estate documents and more.
And all of it can be done online.
I love doing things online.
I do almost all my shopping online.
It's so much easier than having to go somewhere,
especially when you're dealing with legal stuff.
Because in any normal situation,
you would have to set an appointment.
It would have to be from nine to five every day he'd have to take off work or do
something.
We have to figure out how to get to that office on your lunch break.
It's gotta be a way you can figure out how to do all this online.
Well now,
finally there is,
you don't have to be there physically in person.
Most of this stuff that people,
uh,
you know,
most of the legal shit that you have to deal with can all be taken care of like
this.
This is a,
the future.
This is where our world is coming to.
Um,
and so you can go to legal zoom and they can take care of you from start to
finish is the modern way to get legal help.
And for special savings,
be sure to enter Rogan and the referral box at checkout.
Protect your family,
protect your future@legalzoom.com that's all they wrote.
That shit.
Legal Zoom was developed by top attorneys to provide self help services at your
specific direction,
but they are not a law firm and they also can connect you with a third party
attorney.
If all his shit goes haywire,
they can hook you up.
So go to legal zoom.com and make sure you enter the word Rogan in the checkout
box.
We're also brought to you buy naturebox naturebox,
which we can't even keep in here because of you hungry savages people.
People in this room are hungry.
Little savages trying to steal my [inaudible] cashews.
I'm not happy with that man.
I'm not happy with you guys always getting the good shit.
I get my own box now.
I added three more items,
which is like eight items or so and I still with one other person went through
it like in four days.
Yeah Dude,
you can eat,
you put in some food.
Well those packages,
like if you're sitting there watching a movie,
you're just snacking,
you're grazing and
they're good.
And as far as like normal snack food,
it's going to be very hard to find things that are as nutritious and delicious
like legitimately healthy for you.
Like those serratia cashews.
Those are,
those are delicious and you don't have to feel bad about eating them.
I mean,
yeah,
they have calories but you know,
cashews are pretty fucking good for you.
It's cashews with spices on it.
That's it.
And uh,
nature has all sorts.
Naturebox rather has all sorts of options that you can choose from.
Um,
all the different snacks that they have are delicious.
I've had a bunch of different ones and they very nutritionally from like really
healthy,
low sugar,
gluten free.
They have a lot of options and if you're into like Paleo and things along those
lines,
they have a lot of options that fit into those diets.
Especially like gluten free,
low sugar,
um,
or they have things,
even things that have things like,
there's certain stuff like pretzels and things along those lines that no matter
what,
they're not really that health thing,
but there are a lot better than the shit that you'd normally would get in your
vending machine.
And they're delicious.
Some of the stuff I'm so addicted to these big apple pineapples,
I don't know how they make it.
So those are yummy.
I think they have smaller because if you look at the how they're cut,
it's not a huge pineapple.
Maybe it's,
it's sweeter because it's,
I dunno,
maybe it's good,
but I think the smaller is because it shrinks through the dehydration process.
But I don't want him making shit up.
Um,
dark cocoa almonds are also the bomb.
Diggity they have a lot of great stuff there at naturebox.
Very,
very happy with them.
And uh,
everybody is here too.
They,
like I said,
we devour the shit quick.
I'm going to have to start ordering two boxes a week.
Yeah,
we leave them around here.
They're gone.
Um,
but what I like about it,
zero trans fats,
zero high fructose corn syrup,
which are two things that are really troublesome and most American diets,
these are all natural.
You're going to find no artificial sweeteners,
no bullshit,
no GMO.
Um,
they'll,
they'll have plenty of them that are low on sugar or non GMO there with or
without gluten and they shipped for free.
That's what the beautiful thing is.
Peanut butter,
nom nom sir.
Also a good one.
Go to naturebox.com right now and you will get 50% off your months.
First box.
That's naturebox.com/rogan that's where you want to go.
naturebox.com/rogan for 50% off your months.
First box.
But try to dark cocoa almonds kid.
They're very yum.
Yum.
The lemon pucker or pistachios are really good.
And also the sunflower seeds,
all the different ones they have,
I highly recommend note just going crazy and it's like $3 extra per snack,
a PR a month.
I got an extra three.
I wish I got an extra 10 because you'll just fall in love with all these snacks.
I promise you
they're doing a good job.
Yeah,
I liked that.
They,
I like what they're doing.
There's stuff's yummy.
I haven't found one thing that's not yummy.
Uh,
like when you can consistently count on something,
and again,
you're not,
you're not going to feel guilty about it.
You can get some pretty nutritious stuff from them,
you know,
so go,
go to naturebox.com/rogan and in Joe,
I as my new song,
I wrote for them how beautiful my voices copyright like angels,
Bro.
It's like from angels were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com but it's
o,
n,
I t we are a human optimization website and we sell you all the tools you need
to get your shit and gear,
whether it's get your strength on with some kettle bells.
We have primal bells,
which are artistically made kettle bells that look like gorillas and apes in a
rang of tanks.
And we have Zombie kettlebells where you can prepare yourself for the upcoming
apocalypse because Jenny Mccarthy doesn't want anybody getting any vaccines.
So shit goes haywire and there's some fucking crazy Mackie vaxxers vaxxers yeah.
And anti-vaxxer anti-vaxxer the Anti vaccs folks.
Um,
we sell,
uh,
all sorts of Shit to prepare yourself physically and mentally.
Uh,
what,
what does it mean?
It means like we sell you exercise equipment that has been shown to develop what
they call functional strength.
I mean strength that you can apply very directly to athletics strength that you
can apply directly to martial arts,
especially primal bells,
the kettle bells,
the plain kettlebells,
any of the things in those design done with,
uh,
with good form.
And that is a key part is doing done with good form.
We're will noticeably increase your functional strength.
It's your ability to do shit like pick up a chair and move it around your
apartment.
Like you can do that better if you're stronger.
It's like,
it's,
it's better to have a body that works well.
And the,
uh,
Kettlebell packages that we provide,
there are numerous,
all sorts of different sizes.
We'll sell you two and three different sizes and weights.
And we also have great EQ shall exercise videos.
These,
um,
the fitness DVDs,
especially my favorites,
the Keith Weber Cardio Kettlebell workout.
I was talking about this long before we were ever selling this,
the extreme kettlebell cardio workout we have.
I think we,
the first one's sold out.
They sell like crazy.
This dude's a bad mother fucker.
That's Keith Weber Guy.
He goes on a beach and he starts swinging kettlebells and you just try to keep
up with him.
He counts every down,
shows you the exercise counts you down.
And he tried to keep up.
And this dude is an animal.
It's a fucking fantastic workout is my all time favorite.
It says,
if you go there,
it says powerful.
Like it says with my name.
That's my quote.
It is powerful.
That fucking thing is spectacular.
He's a bad motherfucker that Keith Webber and I,
that's how long does it take to look like him?
Years,
years,
steroids,
growth hormone,
green juice.
I can just buy the DVD and pop again.
You're going to have to starve yourself.
Dehydrate.
That guy's probably got great genetic.
All in all seriousness and you've probably as great genetics on top of it,
but he's obviously shredded.
I think I work out big videos all have different backgrounds cause I've been
watching a girlfriend do a lot of them lately and like,
you know,
do you have the abandoned Jim?
You'll have the outdoor ones on the beach.
They should just have one like in the middle of a Mcdonald's.
That would be good.
That's a good move dude.
Like a food,
like a food court,
food color all around.
Ziller with old people everywhere.
Just watching Walmart,
Walmart.
I like the idea of like you could never get it in a,
in a Mcdonald's.
They would never allow you to write about a food court.
You might be able to actually pull off.
If you blurt out all the different labels,
you might be able to do that.
Just make it like,
you know,
Texas or something like,
yeah,
Arizona.
Tucson are so hot as fuck.
Everybody's angry.
What the fuck he doing?
Man jumping rope on stage in front of my cheeseburger.
You fuck,
that's rude.
That's shrunk.
Stop.
Would be kids,
especially as the guys in really good shape.
That's fucking rude.
I'm trying to enjoy,
this is Chinese chicken salad,
you know,
and you're jumping around in front of me like an asshole
six Paki and shit.
Yeah,
sure.
Right.
You couldn't do that.
He didn't,
they would have to be paid actors,
otherwise you'd be an asshole.
Otherwise.
Well,
I'm going to watch a video of how an asshole works out.
Look at me was June.
I could see enjoy your pizza.
I can see it taking off.
It's like that guy in Miami,
uh,
the Russian guy,
he gets to people's faces,
you know,
like,
do you even lift bro?
That guy?
No,
I don't know.
That is,
you don't really like,
he does this thing where he goes up to guys who are just obviously very jacked
and he's like,
Bro,
do you even lift?
And just like,
does that to like 20 of them?
And do you know what the name of a more,
uh,
somebody,
I guarantee you,
somebody will know who the fuck I'm talking about.
He's like Vitale or something that,
but he's this
big personality Brian Tube.
And we'll start off.
Yeah,
podcasts with that car.
He's great.
We'll start off the podcast as one of his cause.
That sounds awesome.
Uh,
anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com that is o,
n n I t used the Codeword Rogan and you just save 10% off any and all
supplements.
If you're thinking about trying kettlebells are any exercise routine,
and this is not a legal disclaimer,
this is just me as a friend to you.
Say,
please don't be a meathead police.
Start slow.
Please learn the proper form if you can.
If you can afford it,
please hire a personal trainer and see if he'll let you videotape you doing it
to make sure you get the idea that you're doing right.
You can do certain exercises by herself in front of a mirror as long as you have
proper form.
But proper form is critical to avoid injuries,
back injuries especially,
you could tweak yourself,
so please build your body up first,
like slowly.
Do it.
Do it the smart.
If you're not a person that works out on a regular basis,
don't go crazy.
You want a slow build.
You don't want to break everything down.
Don't feel like you're being a pussy.
Like I only worked out 20 minutes today.
I bet 20 minutes is okay.
If you're not in good shape and you want to throw some kettle bells around for
20 minutes,
that is,
I'll do a 20 minute workout all day.
I love 20 minute workouts.
People don't think that's enough.
You can get a good workout in 20 minutes.
My point being,
if you're a person who doesn't exercise on a regular basis,
just slowly get into it.
Don't kill yourself because that's what people do.
They,
they get nutty and they say,
no,
I'm going to only drink water.
No more soda.
I'm going to fucking ruin seven miles every morning and in two weeks you're
exhausted.
You've lost all your momentum,
you've tried too hard,
you went crazy.
Not only that,
but you over compensate.
I'm kind of going through this right now,
uh,
where I've been getting back into yoga now that I have a little bit more
stability and uh,
it's weird because after a really intense yoga class,
I want to go out and drink or like do something unhealthy cause I feel like I've
done something that was a sacrifice.
You know,
you're like,
all right,
now I can get back to my life.
But if you feel the sacrifice,
then you're,
you know,
you're going to fuck yourself over later on by not going for the next three
months or stopping whatever you're doing.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's,
it's also one of those things too that like you,
I felt great satisfaction when I'm on a run of like working out where I don't
have any breaks,
but terrible satisfaction.
If I've slacked off for like two weeks,
if I go like two weeks ago a exercise,
I'm like,
oh my God,
what am I dealing?
Like I'm too busy.
This is crazy.
I got to work out.
I'm going to go fucking bananas here.
There's a big difference between how I,
like I feel like very satisfied.
Like,
I feel like I'm on a good path when I get a run in of like six weeks,
six days a week,
I'm working out fucking feel great.
Feel like getting shit done.
And when I don't feel like a dummy point being,
ladies and gentlemen,
please do this smart please.
If you can,
um,
take it slow and uh,
make sure you watch your diet too.
If you're looking for all these fat loss pills,
like that asshole doctor Oz just got popped in front of Congress for,
listen folks,
there's nothing out that's gonna make you burn fat is getting some shit that's
getting make you a stimulate.
You know,
it's going to stimulate your heart rate.
[inaudible] Jack you up.
But there's really nothing that's been proven that can take a fat person and
make them skinny.
There's some things that can help you burn fat.
There's things that can help your body metabolize calories more efficiently.
Enzymes are a big one.
Probe having,
uh,
the right,
stomach bacteria is big too.
Taking probiotics when at all possible.
You can do that.
Even like Vegan probiotics are actually really good.
Like,
um,
Kraut,
like raw Kraut,
really good for your stomach.
All that stuff's so important.
It's so important to just do start doing some research on what you put into your
body.
Lots of green leafy vegetables.
Goddamn,
that's important.
I eat a lot of Kale and celery and like,
I like Green Spinach and cook it sometimes and I eat it raw sometimes.
That shit so important.
Um,
all these different things are important for optimization of your body.
Okay.
Shit.
Together you fucks and go to onnit.com it's Oh and it uses the codeword Rogan
and you could save 10% of any and all supplements.
Boom.
Oh Brian,
what's the new address for your store?
It's just shop squad.
Oh,
shits shops,
squad.tv.
And if you go to shop squad.tv,
you can get Brian red bands.
Groovy creations of a death squad nature.
Yeah.
And I built it on Squarespace whenever.
Oh,
sponsor shit.
Squarespace added again.
You fucking savages.
Dope tee shirts,
all unique and original designs by my little buddy Brian red band and all of
these available at shop squad,
shop squad
and outside of their live shows,
which has that we're having Bert Kreischer at comic con this
Oh
punch other guys.
Uh,
but you can get them all at shops squad.
Just hit collect lie.
Yeah.
And um,
for Brian's desk squad podcast network,
that's all available on Itunes,
you can subscribe to it.
And he's,
of course he has killed Tony,
which is hilarious.
Great show.
I finally got to do that.
And the new kill Tony is not right now.
Right now.
Me and dom,
I rare and holy shit was dumb.
I rarer funny.
Oh my God,
it was like dom over at its best.
It's like,
well you get to see dom Irrera.
It is snarky,
snarky,
hilarious passed.
He's fucking awesome.
It was really,
really fun.
And some funny comics too and some ones that were terrible,
right?
Perfect.
There's a perfect evening for field training.
She'll tell him he's a,
um,
uh,
podcast bar pal,
Tony Hinchcliffe and the podcast is all,
um,
Tony and the red band.
And a couple of other comics,
we'll sit down and then open minors.
Maybe some of them that have never done comedy ever.
They'll go up and they'll do like a minute and a,
it's really fun.
It's really cool.
And I think it's the closest thing that Brian does right now that I could see
being like a television show.
In fact,
I think you probably better off because it's so good.
I think you'd probably better off not doing it as a television show,
just producing for an online series sort of thing.
Like
and like slowly but surely putting some money into it because I think it's like
a show dude.
Like when I sat down in it,
you know what it felt like.
I was like,
this could easily be a comedy central show easily.
It's an easy premise to understand.
It's great fun.
You have comics giving advice to some comics and other ones that are just
insufferable that you just,
you have,
don't just say you want to stay by me out to one.
It was really good with,
yeah.
So fun.
I think Tony Hinchcliffe was there and also,
um,
princess chank,
she was there that week.
Tony Design this idea.
Yeah,
we both came up with it.
We started,
he had an idea of that at the beginning and then we just kind of made it more of
a show.
We added things like the bear,
the West Hollywood bear,
and like the time limits we had the reoccurring females that come every show.
So yeah,
it started out who are the two girls again?
Sarah wine shank and Kimberly Condon.
These checks do a new,
a new minute every week,
one new minute every week.
If you only knew how hard that is for someone who's just started talking to do
comedy and his only been doing comedy.
Why while they've been on this show.
So they've only been doing it for like a year,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
just that we just had our one year anniversary.
Okay.
So they've only been doing it for that long and every week they do a new minute
that the internet gets to listen to fucking incredibly courageous.
Like as far as comedians go,
that's incredibly courageous for a pro of a,
like a longterm pro to commit to a minute every week.
That will be hard.
Like if someone said,
hey,
you want to do a new minute every week,
I'd be like,
Ooh,
that I put online.
Like sometimes a minute it's not ready.
Like I'll try it.
I'm like this fucking jokes not ready.
Well guess what?
I'm sorry.
It's very unfortunate,
but the only way for it to get ready,
cause I have to tell it a bunch of times and it's gotta Eat Dick.
It's just got to,
sorry if you were there when an eight deck one day it'll be awesome,
but they don't start out awesome.
They start out in this weird way and they sort of morph and grow well to be able
to do that,
live on the Internet in front of a live audience and do a new minute every week.
Those chicks have fucking some serious chutzpah.
Yeah,
it's great.
And it,
what's,
what's really interesting is that the one girl who also is a usually on
dysentery with me,
Sarah,
Sarah wine shank.
And then Kimberly quick,
quick college,
uh,
and she was about to graduate and quit college and started comedy on the show.
So you saw the first set she did all the way up to a year later.
So awesome.
Yeah,
it's,
it's any,
we've had so much weird drama too.
We had this guy that dressed up as like an iron man,
you know,
and,
and you know,
he had drama and now we have like a weekly guest.
I couldn't imagine he would have drama that we have a weekly guy that dresses up
as this guy called the iron patriot and a,
we have,
we had Jesus on your episode.
Jesus.
You've had an interesting Jesus like quality to them.
Yeah,
I really did.
Anyway,
um,
go to desk squad.tv for a,
all the information on upcoming shows,
podcasts,
download,
and there's a link there also to shop squad.
So shop squad.
Dot TV.
Yep.
Shop squad.
Dot TV.
All right.
You fucks.
Boom.
Schelok lock,
boom.
David Seaman team.
And he knows things that she does
and he'll tell you them.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Try Rocky podcast all day.
Would you consider this?
That being your opening song,
David Seaman knows about is just thinking that she knew a,
it's got to be my new voicemail message.
I'm feeling like you could do something with this.
I feel it's got a good melody to it.
Yeah,
it's catchy.
It's very catchy.
Devens even knows what you don't know.
Maybe a chorus or pizza at a couple of times.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Doug San hub is a great joke.
Ever seen that joke that he doesn't know about how lazy songwriting is.
He tells the same punchline over and over and over again and it keeps doing it
and everyone gets uncomfortable and he goes,
dad say,
see how fucking easy it is to write a song.
How do you see how lazy songwriters are?
It's really funny too,
because you don't know what he's doing until he's doing it.
Yeah.
He's fucking awesome.
That was off his last special.
Yeah.
Dogs.
Hilarious.
He's being fair.
We see somebody like Adam Levine or a,
I'm only thinking of that because he's in a movie recently thinking about that
cause it's beautiful.
Beautiful.
He just,
he locked down the voice and now he could say anything and people would be like,
yeah,
you know,
like I'll buy that for 99 cents.
Somebody out there would not necessarily me.
Isn't it interesting that he sells acne stuff even though he's on the voice?
Like he's on this big show,
but he's doing an infomercial.
Like he's like,
it's a contrast because usually like someone has to be like sort of sliding till
when they pick up like a proactive or something type of commercial.
Right.
Isn't it a,
are usually like someone was,
oh,
I see what you're saying.
Got Five people are no longer in the prime.
Yeah.
And there's like,
there's a Shannen Doherty
commercial for like,
uh,
some online course or something like that.
Online university courses.
I forgot what it is,
but it's her wearing a bunch of different outfits and it's like,
you know,
that she probably needed money and this is something that came along.
But he's got guys like hugely famous.
They probably gave him so much money that he's like,
fuck,
I don't,
you know,
an afternoon,
$3 million,
whatever.
Like,
if you look at Alec Baldwin,
he has enough money,
right?
And he does the capital one shit constantly.
Yeah,
that's pretty Cheley that,
that seems like kind of embarrassing for somebody that famous to do,
but they must have just given him a shit load of money and it's a good card and
he's like,
well I'll do it.
I wonder if that's worth it.
How many people do you think saw Alec Baldwin and go,
you know what,
that motherfuckers,
my banker,
I got to go to his bank.
How many people did that?
I Dunno.
I just talked about it though.
So I mean it gets it.
He gets you do head,
you wouldn't do it.
Right.
What I do,
what would I sign up because of that?
If you had no bank and you said I've got to get a bank,
I wouldn't choose it because of that.
No,
of course not.
Right.
Who would,
but it might,
it might like slide the balance.
If it was,
if I was already thinking like should I go with capital one or somebody else,
I might go,
well I liked Alec Baldwin
20 years ago and red Octobers.
He's been good.
A bunch of movies,
right?
Fucking Glengarry Glen Ross,
the park I hate when anybody tells me that was over the top.
Oh so over the top.
What that Shane with the watch and the whole piece for closers.
Yeah,
that was a fucking great scene.
he was a dick.
He was,
that was his character.
He fuck people get weird with him cause he's so goofy in real life.
You know,
he does so much goofy shit in real life that people don't respect his acting.
That dude can act as dick off.
You really can.
Fuck yeah,
he can that Glen Gary,
Glen Ross scene is fucking fantastic.
He's vicious.
Fucking cold,
hard capitalist.
And he's like,
this is the army.
You pussies.
You don't get the Glengarry Glen Ross leads.
What did it say?
Only close to get those leads.
Yeah.
That's a great fucking scene.
That poor guy's always duking it out though with somebody.
It's like a flight attendant or recently as the cops arrested him for riding his
bike the wrong way,
he's going to like the wrong way on a street.
You know,
you can't run your bike there.
It would
shut up.
They cuff him.
New York cops so happier to cuff you.
If you're a fucking actor,
they're happy to cough you.
Oh,
we coughed Alec Baldwin today was awesome.
He smelled like liquor riding his bike drunk going down the wrong way
that that guys always in some sort of a dispute with someone.
But the fun interesting people are,
you know,
I mean Mel Gibson,
you tell me Mel gives,
it did become more interesting to you after you heard him scream at his
girlfriend.
You should shut up and blow me.
His last name is actually pretty good.
The one about him escaping from Mexico.
I saw that.
Yeah,
I was a con.
This is actually like,
it's completely psychotic,
but it was really entertaining.
You know,
he's kind of embracing it,
right?
It's embracing that he's crazy.
Like he's in the expendables movie,
you know,
he's embracing the,
the crazy aspects of all those recordings.
He's like the first casualty to that kind of shit.
Like the first real casualty to a big time movie star being sort of exposed like
as a buy a,
I mean,
whatever you want to call or what would you call it,
Brian?
I don't want the temperatures.
Yeah,
something along those.
I don't know how to be,
I don't want to be sued to,
no,
I mean,
I'm like a,
that's an old term for catch wrestling.
Yeah.
A lot of those rushes,
they knew a lot of samba very similar to catch wrestling.
This is your call and asked for an escort dude.
You said that's a hooker.
How dare you?
I don't think she was that.
I think she was a mercenary though.
And uh,
her,
uh,
approach recording this crazy man.
It's Creamy,
but maybe,
you know what?
If you're that chick,
how else do you share that motherfucker doesn't kill you?
How do you know he's not going to Oju and all defense?
I mean,
in her defense,
everyone looked at it like that.
That woman was even what she did was evil.
It was that the whole thing's a disaster.
Okay,
let's stop thinking there's a black and white on this motherfucker.
That whole,
the whole situation was a total disaster.
You had a guy screaming you fucking cunt.
He's screaming,
I hope you get raped by a pack of niggers.
That's when he screamed.
He screamed that on a recording.
Okay,
so he's clearly out of his fucking mind.
Isn't that amazing how many chances we give?
People are like,
yeah,
I'll go see his movie after that.
Yeah.
But my point being like,
she's probably out of her mind too.
Yeah.
You know,
she recorded him doing all this shit.
Like she put it out and she sold it.
I don't know how it got loose.
Got Her 15 grand from TMZ or something,
whatever it was.
But what's,
what's fascinating on,
on both accounts is that like they're together.
They mean what,
what,
what caused her to be what they mean.
But both of them are making terrible choices.
You know,
she's recording him.
He's completely insane.
It's like you're getting caught up in this whirlwind of Kookiness.
But in her defense,
how else would she react if she had a child with this guy?
And he's screaming and yelling crazy shit like that.
Like you don't,
you know,
everybody looks at in terms of like she was mercenary and I agree.
She probably was definitely mercenary,
but a guy like that,
that's how it works.
If you're fucking 60 years old and you're starting to get old looking and you
have this unbelievably hot young Russian check was really into,
you should probably suspect something.
You should probably suspect that she's not in love with the way you look.
She's not as attracted to you as you are to her.
You should probably suspect that she knows that you are an incredibly rich guy
who made like $300 million or something on the passion of the Christ.
Right.
What was,
how much money do you make?
Something insane,
right?
Funder it all himself lethal weapon at least.
Yeah.
I mean I don't think he made that model that he owned that one,
but he owned the thing about the passion of the Christ,
that he funded it himself and it was a huge international Fox News obsessed over
that for like a month.
A lot of people went out to see it,
I'm sure too at that movie,
was he huge?
The Passion of the Christ?
Let's find out how much money that made.
Let's guess before we look.
I said it's dead now though.
Have you ever heard anyone saying they saw it on TV?
Like they don't play that at all.
You can't even buy that anymore probably.
Oh,
I'm sure you can.
But I think what happened?
What do you that Jim Caviezel guy.
It didn't work again for a long time.
And you got to play Jesus.
Yeah,
he didn't work again for a long time.
He's doing something now.
Is he in the desert now?
Like wandering around about 20 years,
man,
I think he's on a show now or maybe a new movie now.
I don't know.
But he's doing some stuff now.
He's a very good actor.
So it's kind of unfortunate.
But I heard they didn't want a little cries.
Um,
let's guess,
um,
what do you guests before we look at how much money it made?
I don't know,
but I bet Daniel Day Lewis would have been a way better Jesus,
because he would have really gotten into it.
Yeah.
I'm going to go up 150 million.
That's my number.
Brian,
don't cheat.
Don't cheat.
You can't be cheating.
We're having a competition yet,
bro.
Hey,
hey.
Hey.
Don't let that fucking bitch.
Okay.
Oh my God is bigger than I thought.
Really bigger than you think.
I would say.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
$215 million.
Keep going,
bitch.
Wow.
That's just domestic son.
Ready for this domestic 370,274,604
foreign,
another 241,116,490
holy shit.
You guys are going to see Jesus coin in the next few weeks,
so more than half a billion dollar just driven by people supporting him because
he's
pursuing a religious topic and most of the time how I would ignore is that dude,
it's opening weekend was $83 million.
How much did it cost to make though?
I don't know,
man.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Three look at this shit.
3000 theaters.
Wow.
$27,000 a show average.
Ain't never think about it that way.
You don't.
You ever think about it when you're looking at like what the actual numbers are
for a movie like that,
$83 million a made in the first week out.
Suck it.
I'm Mel Gibson Karate.
That was a crazy movie too,
if you,
if you've watched it,
it was just the entire movie was like this sadist dream.
I just guy just getting the fuck beat out of them and it's so hard to discern a
plot and it's all implied.
Like you have to know that the guys already Jesus for the movie to have any sort
of an impact.
So it was essentially a movie that he made for the insiders.
Like you made it for the people that already knew that Jesus story.
Because if you didn't know who Jesus was and you saw that movie wasn't very
informative on who Jesus's,
it was kind of weird.
It was like,
why are they beating the fuck out of his colleague?
What's going on?
How come he's not worried?
He's not even freaking out.
He's got magic.
He doesn't use it.
How can we start using the magic while you're letting those guys beat the fuck
out of you?
Software,
religious people.
It hadn't had $30 million budget.
Awesome.
Kapow so $53 million.
The first look at this fucking look at these numbers.
370 million,
782,930 domestic sock.
So Mel Gibson was just
to scream at this Russian chick,
you know,
I mean that was probably what was going on.
His head shot up and blow man.
Hey he didn't,
he like fun to her like recording sessions and stuff.
Like it was trying to like,
she was trying to be a singer.
That's right.
So sorted,
sorted,
sad.
You see the,
the,
the video that I posted of the two women stealing,
uh,
some guys,
like furniture or whatever,
those things are on the beach when you have like a big tent and he,
you know,
he caught Anna.
Yeah,
Cabana.
He walked,
checks are stealing it.
He walked up on him going,
excuse me.
Hey,
how are you guys doing today?
And it's older women in Florida.
We're just took all his bags and stuff and they had them all in the middle and
then they were taking down his thing and acting like it was theirs and condoms,
stealing it.
The second he's,
he's like,
get the fuck away from it.
You know,
they start coming at him like and attacking them.
It is one of,
it's one of those videos like that,
that draw play the drone video times.
And here's another one,
dude,
I got to see this.
It's got a backlog of awesome videos.
Okay.
Any Shit?
Oh,
you need some help?
Yeah.
This is our stuff.
Yes.
No,
it is.
This is all ours.
All of it.
The chairs,
the bag.
This is all our stuff.
My kids.
Yeah,
that's my kids.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
It's what these olds do.
They steal from the young.
I want to see.
It's okay.
I'll let it slide,
but I'm glad I made it in time.
No,
no,
no.
Step away from my shit.
How about that?
And then I'm going to take a camera and putting in the grass that you would like
that
whoa.
Was that real?
Yeah,
it seems to be real.
I mean,
it's being reported on use and stuff like that.
He's got over 1.6 million hits and it cost nothing to make.
I wonder if you shut the phone off and whipped her ass.
Yeah,
right.
I've been trying to search it,
uh,
you know,
news reports for it and see like an official,
like a police report or anything.
I just don't think he filed the police.
But I looked at it as older videos and it was just him and his kids,
you know,
singing cars and stuff,
so it,
it doesn't seem like he added no extra that praying group,
but he actually did catch it.
Well.
Well look man,
young criminals become older.
Criminals know,
you see some 60 year old ladies.
Don't just assume that they're sweet and kind because they look like your mom.
Right.
You know,
there's,
I have some friends that have moms that are criminals to stray criminals.
You know,
I'm,
I'm my friend,
his mom and his dad,
both of them scamming credit card scams,
all kinds of crazy shit.
Like,
you can't,
if they're following you,
you gotta go a circuitous route.
The fuck away from them.
They want,
you don't want them knowing where you live there.
They're criminals and they,
but they look like grandpa's.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean that's,
that happens.
You can get those.
Does that boil your blood at all?
Cause that gets my heart racing.
It does get your heart rate.
You always get your heart rate to be being attacked while you're holding a
camera.
I know.
Remember the,
yeah,
do remember it.
Yeah.
You should really talk about that.
Well we almost had an incident with young Brian,
but yeah,
I mean hitting people,
people hitting people like that,
like went,
then obviously they're stealing this guy stuff.
All right.
And they're hitting him and I wonder how long coming out on was it therefore
like was it left there for hours?
Good question.
Five minutes.
Was it a setup?
Who knows?
Moon fucking know.
That would be a crazy thing to do.
Set some shit out and then set a camera up from distance and then when it starts
stealing it,
come down and go,
hey,
fuck,
I understand that my style,
if you were saying that the rest of his social media stuff,
family,
they know like singing in the car.
I hope he's right.
What if he was on Ambien and shit?
It wasn't really his stuff.
And they break the fuck out of a,
we're taking his side.
You know,
Jamie,
you got to find out if it's real.
I don't know if it's
real.
So,
um,
I can't really comment,
but if it is real and they were stealing stuff and then they were beating him up
at what point in time,
like if you know,
those women are criminals,
like Brian,
let me ask you this.
You're not a violent guy at all.
You're a very friendly guy.
And if you were in a situation like that,
we were,
stuff was left out and you came up to it and these old ladies were,
we're stealing your stuff.
And then when you start talking about it,
they,
uh,
put the camera down and they started hitting on you.
Would you fight back?
Uh,
I would keep the video on as much as possible and then kick away and I kind of,
did you go to your back and do like a guard?
No,
I would do strong arm.
Uh,
I would do,
you know,
like just the Heisman.
Yeah.
Just like get the fuck away from me while recording.
You know,
I've been in situations like this before.
I mean I always pull out my camera immediately and hit record.
I had a weird police incident that happened recently that I pulled out my camera
to start recording him while he was talking to me.
You know,
it's just like I am now to the point where accorded a cop.
I'm not showing it.
No,
I have to.
Yeah.
You want to court?
No,
no,
no.
It happened.
No,
I just don't.
Um,
uh,
I'll say that a house,
not in Burbank.
Was There underage drinking involved?
No,
but we are at or at this person's house and uh,
we were just talking by my car and the cop pulls up and just comes out and goes,
Sirk Sirk I need to see your Id.
And,
and I'm just like,
Eh,
this is my house.
And Goes,
oh right,
I don't care.
What are you doing here?
And he just started like,
like yelling at you and all of a sudden,
and it's just like,
come on,
what's up?
All right,
hold on.
I pull out my recorder and I'm going,
well,
what's the problem officer?
This is my house.
You're on my property.
What is going on?
He goes,
I need to see your Id.
And you know,
it was just like this whole thing.
It's like finally we just being like,
like,
why the fuck are you,
I mean,
bothering me was impossible
that they were looking for someone who looks like you who had done something
fucked up.
Now they were on foot.
What he says is,
he's like,
I just find it peculiar that you're sitting outside this house at two o'clock
with that book bag.
And I'm like,
yeah,
it's just got off work.
I this,
this camera gear,
it was from kill Tony.
And I was like,
this is all my camera gear.
And he goes,
yeah,
but you and I'm like,
so I'm not allowed to be at my house on my property with a book bag without
getting yelled at at what it's like to be black.
They're allowed to say no.
It's like to be black.
Yeah.
You had a taste of it.
I,
it's,
you know,
I understand what he was doing,
but I also understand work.
Like what do you mean in this girl we're having a serious conversation.
He just cock blocked and ruined everything that I've ever,
right.
Yeah.
I've built up to like,
there was like a magic part that was coming on,
you know,
she's about to go,
okay,
I'll come in and fuck you.
You know,
and now it's ruined because now it's just like,
what the fuck happened?
I need to go home.
It's late.
You know,
indeed that's interfering.
It's mine.
He caught fucking rights.
Definitely fine.
If he asks you questions,
I mean it's definitely fine if he sees you standing on the lawn of this house
and he wonders whether or not you're going in,
but then he's got to let it go.
He doesn't have any rights beyond that.
The problem is once someone starts to think that you're guilty of something,
they want to,
they want to believe that they were right.
You know,
they want,
especially if there's any sort of a hostility between you and them.
Sometimes people perceive that cops perceive that,
like any disrespect between them as like some resistance of what they do or
their authority.
So they want to impose it on you now and get you to do something and you're
like,
I'm not fucking doing that.
And then all of a sudden you were involved in this altercation over nothing.
You know,
and you were innocent.
You're an innocent person.
But the,
the ego,
the cop gets in the way.
That definitely can happen with the wrong personalities.
Even with good cops.
There's also been a lot of incidences lately where I feel like,
especially when I'm in my car,
I'm like,
man,
I need to remember to just put my Gopro on in my car and just record everything.
I'm doing it while I'm driving because I mean there's been so much crazy shit
that that's been like,
I saw a guy jumped into traffic the other day and get hit and I'm like,
why didn't you do that?
Like I watched him jump into it like,
and he was just like a drug addict and he,
you know,
I don't know what he was doing.
I think it was alive and everything.
I just kept on driving.
Like I saw a woman shitting.
Like I think I said I shitting in the middle of the street.
Like I'm like,
what?
But I also think like,
especially with these videos that have been coming up,
just women attacking and like Anthony gets saying,
that woman said that he was going to,
that woman has got like if he called the police was going to say that he was
raped,
she was raped or you know,
attacking her
or whatever.
That's what he said,
that she said that,
um,
when she was hitting him,
she was saying that she was going to say that he sexually assaulted her.
Right,
right.
And by the way,
it's the and Anthony thing.
Yeah.
The opie and Anthony thing,
if you don't know,
um,
our friends open Anthony Anthony.
Cool.
Mia was in New York City and he was taking photographs and they got a photograph
of a woman and this woman got very upset that he took a photograph of her.
So some sort of an altercation took place.
Um,
some words were exchanged and she started hitting him.
So she was hitting him.
And if you don't know Anthony,
you don't know that he's a gun nut and like a legit gun,
not who actually has a license to conceal carry in New York City,
which is incredibly difficult to obtain.
But here's one strike for,
uh,
people who want people to have guns.
Anthony never pulled out that gun,
never even seen it.
He obviously felt threatened.
He was getting hit by this one woman who,
Anthony is a nice guy,
but he is,
you know,
51 years old,
loves his drinking and I don't think he lifts weights that much.
It's not like he's just like big scary,
you know Quentin Jackson,
rampage Jackson looking dude,
you know he's a,
he's a thin guy.
He's not a,
not a physically imposing guy and this chick is beaten on him and he's got a gun
on them.
I don't,
I wasn't there.
So obviously I don't know what the tone the situation was.
I don't know how it got started.
I don't know.
I've read very little about it other than he went on this rampage calling her an
animal and a cunt and all this,
all these different,
but what's,
what's hilarious is everything that he said and his Twitter rampage that they're
firing him before he said on the radio show and they hired him for
the radio show.
If you paid attention to what he said over the years and why he's entertaining
in how he says it,
he gets crazy about racial situations.
He gets crazy about certain aspects of the African American community and he's
done it for ever.
And so these things that he said after getting punched that they were surprising
to serious who had heard him say these things and they gave him checks.
It's kind of hilarious.
And also like one of the things that people are pointing out all over la all
over.
Um,
the twittersphere is they're showing all these lyrics to rap songs that Sirius
has aired since Anthony got fired for tweeting.
And the lyrics are ridiculous.
I mean,
oh yeah,
dude,
it's hardcore rap.
They,
they air hardcore rap lyrics.
So they've got,
you know,
Nigga this and shoot,
suck my dick and this bitch isn't that pitches.
And you know,
the craziest,
most a radical,
you know,
hip hop shit.
And yet Anthony gets in trouble for this thing that he did where he went on this
Twitter rampage and said a bunch of shit that he's,
I bet you could.
I bet if someone was a real opiate Anthony Fan,
you could probably go back through all the opiate Anthony shows and piece
together him actually saying those words that are in those tweaks
that's serious makes money off of racist.
That's serious.
Makes money off of,
well,
you know what man,
here's the thing.
Um,
I think what happens is that these companies get really terrified of the Twitter
storm.
Yeah.
They get like,
you saw that with a,
well you see it all the time with the sponsors for rush Limbaugh,
but you see it with or I believe conservative radio in general.
You see it with,
uh,
like Donald Trump had a,
I forget what it was,
a tie collection or some shit at Macy's.
Then there are all these people on Twitter like tweeting the Macy's account.
Like don't support him because I don't remember what the issue was,
but they,
once it gets going,
the company feels overwhelmed and they're like,
we have to respond because a thousand people just retweeted this thing and they,
I think they just feel like the best route is the 48 laws of power thing where
you just put a head on the chopping block and,
and think later.
Oh,
I see their point of view.
I do if you,
but I don't think they were fans of the opiate Anthony show.
That's what I think is part of what's going on.
I don't think they listened.
I think there weren't a lot of people could play anything.
They just like the money coming in.
So it's a great show.
It's the reason why we're doing this show.
The reason why we're doing this shows because of opie and Anthony.
Oh,
a lot of ways.
There's a direct chain of influences.
Um,
one of them being Tom Green,
Tom Green had his own show in his house way back in the day.
And I remember going over there and be like,
this is the craziest shit ever.
He's got server room,
he's got a Goddamn server room with cables all through his living room and he
turned his living room into a television show.
He just did a little too early.
He had a great innovative idea.
He did it a little too early.
That influence us.
Anthony Kumina me greatly.
When he did live at the compound,
he did,
he does this thing live at the compound where he set up a studio in his house in
Long Island and in his,
in his basement he has a green screen and he'll fucking sing while he's holding
guns.
Dude,
he's singing songs.
He's singing karaoke while he's holding assault rifles.
All right.
And that,
I don't know if they have a page,
but that shit is hilarious and I saw him doing that while he was still on opie
and Anthony who was doing it just for fun and I was like,
oh my God,
this is genius.
He set up a green screen.
He set up in a a real like professional stage with a green screen and behind the
green screen and you would have like video of Manhattan or he would have like,
like I was going to totally steal that idea.
I might still put a green screen behind me.
It for a w if we do get that track quarter cried tri caster thing that we'll do
it.
Uh,
in respect to Anthony,
I have a,
I have a green screen in my apartment.
Kind of weird shit.
Are you up to,
it's kind of a kind of low end cause it's just the green cloth that's the right
color.
Right.
But then you use I movie,
you switch out the background and suddenly instead of being in your apartment,
you have this subtle background or maybe it's the city or wherever the fuck it
is.
You find something on flicker and then people take it a little bit more
seriously because you're not just some crazy rambling in your kitchen.
You're like,
oh I see somebody spent a little bit of time on this and people will watch.
I like that.
Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
Everybody out there should do it.
Go on Amazon and get like a green screen kit.
They're not expensive.
That's not everybody.
If you're like just the fucking idiot,
I'll do it.
But if you have something to say,
this is the way to not seem like a crazy person on youtube.
A crazy person on youtube just told you how to not say things and do things to
make you know completely everybody on Youtube.
That's like one of the easiest ways to dismiss people.
Always just kind of a youtube show fucking guy on youtube saying which crazy
show on youtube.
Right?
Isn't that like,
it's sort of a,
a term of dismissal,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I think it's all changing.
I think now people are kind of,
uh,
I'm not even a big Youtuber,
I just do it from time to time.
But I think people are definitely intimidated by things like the young Turks
where it is clear that it's more powerful than half the cable shows out there.
And so the only thing they can do,
and this is something that he's talked about,
his dismiss it and be like,
oh,
it's not the real thing.
But yeah,
this is realer than probably anything on the radio right now.
So we're,
uh,
so what he's doing is realer than,
I mean his numbers,
he can verify the numbers that they're using.
Like Nielsen's,
yeah,
come on you two dozen.
Youtube does not fuck around with their numbers.
They're very serious about it.
Well,
they absolutely,
that's absolutely true.
But it's also that it's a number that you could watch and see.
I mean,
like you can't,
you can tell me whatever you want about the Nielsens,
but the reality is you only have a certain amount of households.
Like I don't know how many,
it's,
there's some fuckery in there.
There's some number of differences and they,
they can tell you all,
all day long.
Well,
we've just statistically analyzed how well it works.
I don't believe you.
You know why I don't believe you?
Because the Internet says so.
Well,
it's in their best interest to inflate their numbers.
They get more advertising dollars.
That's probably what's happening,
but I don't need think
of would think it's inflating.
I think by their algorithm,
this is what the numbers that they've calculated,
it's probably pretty close.
They're probably pretty close.
But why would you want pretty close?
When do,
you can get absolutely exact and that's what the Internet offers.
So when they talk shit on like chank and like the young Turks,
which just look at the numbers,
look at how many downloads.
You know what that is?
That's real.
It's a real number.
It's not like 15,000 households all across the Midwest,
you know?
I mean,
I don't understand the Nielsens at all.
I never understood it.
It's,
it's Voodoo and unless they can accurately,
every time you wash something,
a little counter should go over.
Every time you watch it at home where you watch it.
Maybe it's a an app that we all were on their fucking Google glasses or
something like that,
that measures what you're watching so we can all figure it out.
But until they do that,
you don't really know.
It should already have that though.
Based on what cable companies know,
what channel you're watching,
do what?
They don't share that information.
They say they know how many people are watching what on satellite,
but they can't use it as a ratings thing because it's probably like some NSA
type shit.
You're not even supposed to be doing that.
And that's supposed to be monitoring people's viewing habits and find out that
they've been ordering Debbie,
Debbie dirty debutantes
over and over again and clearing their history.
You know,
I do.
I don't think that does shit.
I think there's probably a second copy somewhere.
It goes off into the cloud and you're,
especially if you're ordering some freak shit,
if you're ordering some freak shit to hear about the,
uh,
there was a thing about tour where apparently one of the NSA programs actually
flags you for further review.
If you're using tour tour,
what's tour?
That's the anonymous anonymized web browser that people use to surf without
giving away their identity.
Really?
Yeah.
So if you use it,
you get flagged.
Exactly.
Just for using it.
They consider you to be like some kind of elevated or know the word they used as
extremists,
which I think is so ridiculous because the people use tour,
our journalists,
uh,
activists and probably like bored kids in college who were like,
I'm going to try tour.
Um,
like they said,
extremists,
the fuck are you talking about dude,
who are the biggest freaks in the world?
Journalists and college kids.
Every one of them rolls on an Internet course.
That would be like the number one way to,
I've only used it once.
The problem is it's way slow.
It needs to really,
it's frustrating to use.
You didn't worry when you signed up to use it that you would be flagged.
I assume I'm already on there.
I think.
I think I'm on a good one.
I think I talked to the other day about,
you know,
you imagine though for a second there you started to sweat it.
No,
I was excited.
I was like,
Ooh,
let's hear about this.
But uh,
no.
Um,
the tour issue,
it just goes to show you how fucked up things are that they considered that
extreme.
Yeah.
It's kind of weird that you're preserving your anonymity would automatically put
you in this weird bracket.
But I guess like if you thought about like who are the extreme people that would
use this,
that would be dangerous and how many of the people,
I guess their definition of dangerous in our definition is different.
Like,
I would like to see activists,
right.
Network and out,
like companies dumping pollution.
I don't really give a shit about that,
want to see that happen,
but they consider that to be,
you know,
a threat to national security because it threatens the balance of power.
But yeah,
no,
you're totally right.
It's,
uh,
it's,
it's easy to make both arguments.
That's the problem.
It's an,
it's one of those situations where,
yeah,
if you did that and you looked at everybody's background when you found them
using this and analyzing,
analyzing it,
anonymous,
anonymizing and optimizing and optimizing web browser,
you'd go,
well,
you know,
it's probably a good pool to look through.
The thing is like could I accurately rely on them to look at a guy like David
Seaman and go,
oh no,
this is actually just a smart young guy who's looking at the world and doesn't
like all the bullshit he sees and he thinks that we can do better.
It really that simple.
That's your agenda.
That's how I'd take you.
Am I accurate in my assessment of view or are you
pretty accurate?
I get frustrated by person.
I get frustrated by seeing stupidity and callousness and I think we're seeing
like a nice combination of that and we're also on the other side seeing progress
and I'm attracted to progress so I'm just trying to like push the ball and you
know,
talk about things that I think are actually helping while also reminding people
that a lot of this stuff has not been fixed.
I think you were also doing a great service in that you are doing it in this
uncensored form through the Internet very courageously and you're a part of
what's now like this whole,
there's a,
and it's all connected in a lot of ways to the the new corporations to like
Google and these new technological corporations.
They all seem to have an ethic about them that didn't exist and some of the
other corporations that we think of,
whether it's fossil fuel corporations or carb manufacturers or anything along
those lines,
we don't think of them as being like particularly ethical,
particularly tolerant.
But you think about that when it comes to like tech companies like Google is
trying and Vr,
there's companies like Google especially it was a,
they're very upset about all this net neutrality shit.
They're very upset about all this.
This,
this the possibility that the Internet is going to be regulated by the
government.
Like the,
they're going to be able to monitor and track like streams and how fast.
Yeah,
I was just,
you get,
I was just thinking about this earlier today cause I was trying to figure out
what is the problem.
Like how do we get to a place where a company can be,
I was thinking of Twitter,
like a company can take advantage of that capitalistic impulse towards,
you know,
constant progress,
constant new products.
We're finding more,
make it more addictive,
make it easier to use.
So Twitter because they're profit focus,
that's what they're doing.
And because they're in the right kind of business where there they make their
money from giving small people a voice.
Like that's obviously an oversimplification,
but that's what Twitter does.
And so that capitalistic thing,
that machine works really well and making Twitter better and better at least in
the next couple of years until something better comes along and replaces it.
But then you get companies like,
um,
you know,
the big ISP is the big cable companies were them getting more and more.
I'm like capitalistic efficient and more ruthless isn't actually helping the
rest of us.
It's dragging us down
because they're in charge of this thing.
We all need the internet and if they're only thinking about,
oh,
we can fuck them over a little bit right here and then we can implement this so
when we can have the fast lane for our preferred partners,
they're applying that,
that profit motive to something that is completely against the public interest
and doing it in a very efficient,
uh,
influential way.
Like they have lobbyists working on this shit,
but it's against the public interest to be like lobbying for polluted water and
being like,
well,
we make more selling polluted water.
Too bad you can't do that.
You can't sell people Internet access and pick and choose which sites people are
going to be able to get the fastest.
That'd be like selling me a newspaper and it's like,
oh,
half the photos haven't been printed.
If you want those photos to be printed,
go to our office and we'll print them out for you.
You would not pay for the newspaper.
You'd be like,
fuck this.
I'm never buying your newspaper again.
It's also one of those things where when you're looking at it,
you go,
why?
Why should this be legal?
Why should this be okay?
Well,
it's censorship of,
of,
of what people are putting out there into the world.
Like the whole point of the Internet is that it's not preferential.
Right?
It's control.
Yeah.
There's,
it's,
it's an added element of control and the added element going to large
corporations and not to individuals.
It's going the wrong way.
It's going the opposite way that the internet goes.
Yeah.
The Internet goes to the individual having more ability to communicate the
individual having more resources and what you said about Google seeming to be
more ethical in some ways,
and a lot of these tech companies have the same kind of ethos.
I think.
It's not because they're necessarily better people.
It's because what they're doing,
their industry is non parasitic,
so whereas the cable company,
the only way they can increase their profits is we got this pipeline into your
house.
Let's make more money off of what we own.
Over time,
that becomes parasitic.
Whereas Google essentially built a whole empire off of user generated content.
Anybody who built a website improves Google search.
Anybody who puts shit on Youtube improves the,
you know,
content offering of youtube.
So they make money off of everybody having a voice and they want to protect that
voice.
Cable companies don't give a shit.
They make money off of pumping their networks into your home and they want to
maximize their profit.
And unfortunately they're really powerful and they have a bigger voice than
almost anybody else.
Yeah,
I think that's an interesting way of looking at it.
I think there's probably some of that in there too.
Uh,
but I think that also,
I like to look on the bright side of things.
So I think that what I'm seeing from these new tech companies is just more
tolerance.
And I think that that tolerance is probably due to the influence of the
Internet.
And that's probably how they look.
Google is the Internet.
I mean,
that's what it's about.
So their whole company is essentially about the internet and now phones,
but the phones are also connected to the Internet.
I mean it's a big part of what they do and the ethic of the Internet,
it seems to be like the social ethic seems to be evolving way quicker and way
stronger than at anytime that I can never remember.
And cultural history,
I never remember these like big movements shifts in how people talked and
behaved in the words that were in the words that weren't accepted and you know,
and just w w just these giant trends that take place in just wash through
culture.
They didn't,
they didn't move this quick before.
It's because we practice like a thought mass correction,
which I'm not entirely convinced is a good thing yet.
I still haven't really decided if it's good or bad,
but if you look at that woman who took the flight from London to South Africa
and tweeted out that insensitive shit about like,
you know,
like I hope I don't get aids when I land in Africa or something.
Uh,
she finished it though.
She said,
just kidding.
I'm white.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So even even worse.
So by better you mean?
Yeah,
that's what made it funny.
Before her flight landed in South Africa.
I think she's already lost her job and the global uproar.
So that person learned that this is not socially acceptable.
And why did they learn that?
Because the Internet gave them that lesson.
Well,
she should have been a comedian because that would have been fucking hilarious.
You know if a really funny comedian said that like a licensed last year said
that when she went to Africa Hall,
Shit,
that would be funny.
Is it the wrong thing to say?
Yes,
it most certainly is.
Yeah.
But if you work in PR for some,
I think it was a,
I don't even want to say the company,
but just a big media company.
So you think she was on pills or something?
Like why was she fucking say,
I mean,
what did what,
how could a person in corporate America thing,
it's okay to put some on your Twitter.
I have no idea.
Kidding.
I'm not,
I'm white.
Lol.
We don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy person.
It's funny though.
It's still funny.
It's a horrible thing to say,
but the point is like crazy people are being called out.
There's still crazy,
but now we can call them out.
So you're going to ruin a lot.
Good jokes.
You are.
And a lot of jobs,
people are losing their jobs.
Like Anthony was just for going off Twitter.
Well,
you know,
the,
the Anthony thing is,
um,
it's particularly weird because that's sort of like,
he had been known for that.
Like you guys had a show where it was like,
there were openly joking about racism all the time.
Like the other day he had Amy Schumer on one of the best of shows.
It was from years ago and they were talking about interracial porn and Amy
Schumer was fucking hilarious.
But she was saying that she,
she was so funny,
man.
It was really fun.
And she's so sharp.
Um,
she was saying that she's never fucked a black guy,
but she likes watching black on white porn.
And uh,
Anthony was talking about how sad it was and that,
uh,
his,
his racism won't let him watch it.
Like his racism won't let him watch a black guy fucking a white girl.
There is a certain that is pretty racist if you,
if you can't handle a black man fucking a white person that's praying,
he's joking.
He is a comedian.
I think a lot of people forget it.
It's a comedy show that he's one of the funniest people I know that just doesn't
go on stage and it's a comic.
Yeah,
certainly a comedian.
Yeah.
Whether he goes on stage in front of a live audience or whether he goes,
do you think his rampage was meant to be funny though?
No.
That's the problem.
That's part of the problem.
That's not,
that's not done
for entertainment or for then you're not,
then your profession doesn't really matter.
You see,
I'm up my issue with all these things,
um,
is that like many things in life.
They're not black and white.
You know,
this is not black and white.
I think Anthony is awesome.
I love that dude.
He's one of my favorite people on radio ever.
He's great.
He's just funny as shit.
He's smart as fuck.
He knows a lot of things about different things.
He's very,
he's very interesting the way he looks at the world.
He says a lot of crazy shit about black people.
He does,
he has for a long time.
I don't know his personal experiences.
I don't know what he's around,
where he's formulated these ideas about certain black people.
But I also know that there's a lot of black friends,
Patrice and him were close.
You know,
he's uh,
you know,
black comics that come on the show all the time.
That a friendly with him.
He's not a mean person.
He's not a bad guy.
If you're a nice person,
he'll be nice to you too.
That said,
I don't know what the fuck went down that night.
Who knows?
Yeah.
I mean,
he did get attacked,
which is crazy,
but he's leading up to it.
He also used to always talk about statistics about his city in New York and
stuff like that,
about how,
you know,
the,
the race issues with that.
And so I think that what he,
because he didn't,
when he went off,
he didn't really say all blacks are this,
you know,
he was kind of just talking about the person that attacked and was a savage,
it was what he said.
Yeah.
He called her a continent animal and all this different shit.
If it was a white chick and he called her an animal,
he would have been fun.
Yeah.
And we would have called her the same exact word.
It's,
look,
it's all very tricky.
You know when I always say about when,
whenever you see a situation where two people get into a fight,
it's not always just one guy's fault.
Sometimes it's both guys fault.
Sometimes one a different person.
Like if you talk to this guy,
it would have never turned into a violent altercation and maybe you would walk
away shaking hands.
Sorry man.
Ah,
no worries dude.
And another guy talking to the same guy.
It might lead to a bloody fist fight and it's just a matter of how do you
communicate with people?
Who was this woman?
I've been,
I was in New York City with this chick that I was dating.
We were walking down the street and this girl was so nice.
She was so nice.
I mean she was,
no,
she wasn't,
she wouldn't be mean to anyone ever.
No mean faces.
She didn't have anything like that in her.
So um,
we're walking in,
this black couple is walking in the same direction and the girl steps in between
her and I and pushes this girl that I was with just push their move bitch,
just move bitch.
Cause you know,
we were walking this way and they were walking towards us and she's decided that
that was her spot.
So Jesus,
she has elbow.
This girl said move bitch.
Wow.
She pushed it aside and I am thinking we're about to go to war.
I'm like,
we're going to about to go to war and I'm the knock out the girl first because I
don't want to have to deal with her while I'm hitting out of the guy.
I'm like,
this is about to be a fight.
And then th that chick just turned white bitches or something along the lines
like that,
some white and walked away and kept going.
Fortunately because it was like,
like an all of a sudden the car.
But I was like,
Dad,
I was like close to a fist fight for no reason,
you know?
And it just happened to be that that chick was black and it just happened to be
the girl that I was with was white and blonde.
But that happens.
There's black assholes out there just like there's white hassles out there.
There's Chinese assholes out there,
you know,
that doesn't make me racist.
That makes me scared of people that are assholes and they come in all forms,
Bro.
I,
I grew up in a Boston neighborhood,
Jamaica.
There was Jamaica plain,
the place where I lived at before I moved to Newton,
which was our cushy and Nice Jamaica plain was Phil with his Irish savages.
They were dangerous fucking kids.
These dangers,
Irish kids.
And if you ran into him,
it didn't matter what race they were.
It's like,
who's that?
Who's a savage?
These guilds kids were savages.
Didn't matter if they were white or Chinese.
You walked down the wrong street in Chinatown and you run into some crazy
Chinese gang that wants to fuck you up.
You're not happy.
I mean,
it's not,
it's not better that way.
There's all sorts of races.
Every race contains savages.
Every race contains assholes,
you know,
and the problem is when it's a black person,
it's getting attacked by white guy.
You know,
you gotta be real specific that it's that person that's a piece of shit.
And if some other people jumped in,
it's them that are pieces of shit.
It's not the whole town.
It's not all black people.
It's not,
you know,
it's just,
there's a certain type of person,
whether it's white or black or whatever.
That's a piece of Shit,
you know?
And I don't know if it's this lady,
I don't know why.
Who knows what happened to her that that day,
you know,
who knows what happened to her,
who knows what's going on in her life,
and all of a sudden this guy's taking pictures at her.
She wants to punch him in the face.
Do you remember what time it was?
I,
it was,
I forgot to look to see actually what time it occurred,
but I think it was around two to 3:00 AM wearing the Twitter happens.
Uh,
but uh,
you know,
I understand he's,
if you looked at his photos on Instagram,
he was taking a lot of photos of the city,
a lot of photos of cops and construction workers and [inaudible] and stuff like
that.
I get having a great camera,
uh,
that,
that you're playing,
like New York's empty and you're downtown and you're taking photo and though a
woman's walking in the distance.
Yeah,
you're taking her,
cause it's a photo.
It's,
it's cool.
But,
but,
but you know,
I don't know what happened here,
but what does seem to happen that,
that,
that he did attack him and he didn't have a police or a deal with the police?
No,
no,
he doesn't call nine one one because you figure like they wouldn't do anything.
Right.
You know,
maybe he's right,
but I don't think the right way to handle it is going on Twitter and going
fucking crazy.
And I think that that's something that someone does when you just want to lash
out.
And for him,
he likes to,
uh,
use social media to,
you know,
to get points across.
And that's a point though.
The black on white violence has been a point of interest of his for a long time,
you know,
and there's a reality that exists just like white on black violence exists,
just like all kinds of violence exists.
And Anthony is a guy who was particularly concerned with that.
It's one of the reasons why carries a gun,
right?
I mean,
he's a rare person that has a concealed carry permit in New York City.
He's one of,
it's pretty hard.
It's got a big ass fucking 99.
It was published.
So that's chicken hitting him while he's armed with a deadly weapon.
And then five other people jump in apparently.
And the whole thing is chaos.
And I would have loved to for it to be avoided,
but I think serious lost the potential opportunity to engage in a discussion
about this,
about violence in New York City,
about violence in general,
the people interacting with each other about interacting on social media,
interacting when you're hot with fucking rage and you're just venting and
ranting and consummate a continental.
And what is your actual intent and and what is my job as a representative of
your Sirius Xm?
Am I am allowed to be Anthony or do I have to be Anthony that only thinks like
Sirius XM wants me to think and only tweets like Sirius XM wants me to tweet.
When are you clocked off work?
Exactly.
Now when?
When are you not,
I'm not supporting him right in this,
I'm saying this is,
this is a very tricky situation where the company has to be real careful because
part of what you do is you promote free speech and you,
you have a radio show and you have this network that's uncensored.
There's net was,
it was the coolest thing about Sirius was you could get Howard stern on it and
he could swear it was the greatest thing of all time.
Like from now on,
he's unchained and Opie and Anthony are unchained and comedy is unchained.
You can watch,
you can hear all my bits.
It's totally uncensored.
They have them on Sirius.
It's beautiful.
So if all of a sudden you decide that you don't like what a guy says on Twitter,
so his opinions,
which are very similar that he's voiced on the radio,
very similar,
if not identical,
will now be silenced.
It gets a little squirrely.
The whole thing is a backlash.
It's a backlash to the,
the racism and or implied racism of his tweets.
You know,
look dude,
I do.
I wish that he just went on the radio and explained himself and more than 140
characters.
Yes.
Cause,
I bet he could evented the exact same rage the next day with no Twitter thing
and people would not have had a problem with it if he said it with his words,
if he explained what happened,
there's a real problem with fucking getting out anything super important where
you don't want to have any mistakes and how you're being perceived with 140
characters.
You know,
you're saying cut animal savage,
you don't,
you know,
he's not talking,
he's writing a bunch of shit down.
So you mad that he's conveying those thoughts.
Do you not think that he would have those thoughts up,
this chick hit him?
Do you expect them to be,
you know,
Eh,
angelic and his approach to violence?
Like,
I don't know what you're looking for here because if it's just that you think
that what he said is racist,
have you ever listened to that show because they listened to that show?
He says shit like that all the time.
I'll say if you have a job as a show host or a pundit,
you really need to be allowed to say what you want on your social media,
even if it kind of,
you know,
damages may be Asian,
but no,
but,
because look,
if
he said all Jews need to be thrown into an oven and pissed on while they're on
fire.
No,
no,
that's right.
That's a little bit different.
So,
but,
but is it different because where does,
where does one draw the line?
What if he said that and he's only joking?
It turns out he's actually Jewish.
Is that okay?
I don't know nearly enough about him or the show,
so I really don't know.
I think it's the same thing.
I think when,
when you say something absolutely,
totally awful like that,
like all Jews should be like,
you can't be associated with my company.
Right?
Like you can't,
it's not a serious person at that point.
It's a crazy person.
And it's a dangerous person too because who knows what percentage of the
population's listing that's unhinged.
It's been waiting for a guy like you to come along.
But he didn't do that,
you know?
Well he did his respond to a person who attacked him and then talk in very a
racial terms about the scenario.
And he has in the past on the radio show about what it's like to worry about
black violence on white people.
Yeah.
And,
and that's,
what is that like the young Turks,
uh,
thing you saw,
I don't know if you saw that or not,
but that was,
they called them a racist.
That was one of the worst things I've ever seen.
I lost,
I'm sorry.
All respect for them just based off of that one interview,
because it was completely,
you can know that they don't know the backstory.
They,
they don't know.
They don't listen to the show.
But it's an interesting thing though,
isn't it?
When you're,
you're looking at someone who doesn't know,
Anthony,
doesn't know the show,
doesn't know the backstory and is responding to just deciding everything right
there.
You know that he was perving and he's taking a picture of this woman coming in
off the street and not knowing about all those other pictures that he had taken
and that he is an amateur photographer.
He loves taking pictures in a candid photo of a woman walking down the street.
She was pretty and she had long legs and just said,
nice body look good.
You know,
I've heard three in the morning dressed up like street,
absolutely street meat,
but,
but they jumped on him unfairly and that's like,
that was like Fox News.
It was like,
wait,
aren't you supposed to be the opposite of this?
No,
I don't think it was like Fox News.
I think it was like they perceived what his word.
I'm telling you there's a fucking real problem with saying something like that
at 140 characters.
It's stupid.
Like I've said some dumb shit on Twitter before.
I've had people write full blogs on like one tweet that I had there was like a
joke.
It's just a joke tweet.
I get that.
You could decide that you know you have a green light to write something.
140 characters doesn't work.
It doesn't work for anything important.
If you really had a situation where you thought your life was in danger or you
thought you were,
you know you're going to go unconscious or you're gonna lose your eyesight,
like apparently had like spots on his eyes,
wouldn't you want to hear that?
Like the full version of it?
I think if Anthony just would tell the full version of it on the air and avoid
the tweets,
none of this would've happened.
He would've been able to express himself the exact same way.
That fucking cunt animal,
he would have been able to say whatever he wanted.
He would have been able to talk in depth about black on white violence,
which I'm not saying that's all that exists.
There's plenty of white on black violence.
There's plenty.
I'm saying that it exists.
I mean to pretend it doesn't exist,
it's pretty silly to me to pretend there's not black people that will hit white
people and robbed them.
Just like to pretend is not white people who will hit black people and robbed
them.
Of course it exists.
Yeah.
Racism exists.
Violent racism from random people on both sides can end,
does exist.
So is he right in saying that it exists from them or what do you have to qualify
it first by saying that there's a lot of piece of shit white people out there as
well.
I don't know.
You know,
I don't know,
but in my opinion with what they're doing is silly.
This is a quote from Penn Jillette today.
Penn says this.
If I'm in a position where I cross somebody who was carrying a gun and can,
can defend themselves and hurt me,
and their choice is to write angry stuff on Twitter instead of fighting me back.
Wonderful.
Gandhi.
That's Gandy.
Yeah.
I don't agree with that.
I think just cause you have a gun that doesn't make you any more special and
they're like,
well I didn't use my gun.
It's like that shouldn't even be on the table in the first place.
It certainly should be on the table.
If someone's trying to take your life,
what's the difference between someone punishing you with her knuckles and
someone beating you to death?
How much,
however much of a background do you have in violence?
Have you ever seen someone get knocked unconscious in a street fight?
Uh,
actually yeah,
but on Youtube I've seen in real life I've seen in real life a few times and
it's terrifying.
I saw in real life once in Hollywood,
there was a a moment in front of the comedy store,
we're all hanging out.
It was after a show and this guy and this other guy got in this argument and
there was traffic going by and they're right in front of the House of Blues,
which is directly across the street from the comedy store.
And in the middle of this argument there's back and forth and it's a white guy
and a black guy and you see them start to like swing at each other and the white
guy goes into a full panic.
All I remember is this guy like standing,
like wincing his eyes and flailing with his hands,
like literally had,
it was just in full panic and this black eyes.
I see him hit him and I see cars go in front of it and I don't know what
happened.
I just,
I know that they're hitting each other because the white guy was flailing,
but I don't see the connection.
And then the car goes back,
you know,
the car passes and the guys flat out cold on the concrete just in serious
trouble.
He's in the street,
there's cars going by,
he's in a fight with a guy and he's completely unconscious and everybody's
screaming,
there's cars honking and this guy's out cold on the street.
That guy could die easy.
And again,
we tell you something.
A woman can do that too.
Just like a man can do that to you if you don't think that there's women out
there that can punch you in the face and knock you unconscious cause you've
never been punched by a woman.
There's a lot of women that can punch really fucking hard.
I,
you know this,
see these snacks.
That's my friend Miriam,
Miriam Nakamoto.
She's eight time world Moitai champion.
She beat a man and a kickboxing bout.
She's beautiful.
She's a nice person.
She makes snacks now,
but live.
That chick punches you in the face.
You're fuck Ceville you know,
like for real,
like a regular guy who doesn't know how to fight.
She'll beat the fucking breaks off you.
It's not,
not good.
So he doesn't know anything about this girl.
If the girl starts teeing off on him with left and rights and she's got like
precision punching,
guess what?
You're going to go unconscious.
Yeah.
So should you applaud him for night pulling out his gun?
You shouldn't pull out a gun in that situation.
And he did the right thing so that I agree with them.
Yeah.
I just wouldn't go as far as saying that he is a Gandhi.
Like that's I,
he's choking.
Yeah,
I know.
It's written.
See when it's written,
you get all fucked up.
You get all fucked up.
Even you the regular person.
Yeah,
of course.
It's going to get close.
It's impossible to tell sarcasm.
Like I,
I've thought that he was serious because he's a pretty serious guy.
Like I realize,
I realize he doesn't show in Vegas and ship and he's very serious.
Like he has a lot of serious ideas.
He is serious.
I mean he's joking about that by saying he's gone,
but he's premise,
this series,
the premise is absolutely serious.
It's true.
Is there any way to see a security video of how this went down?
Good question.
Given how,
I mean series is a big company and it's kind of big implications to drop one of
your biggest hosts so well their outrage was all over online.
You know what I mean?
People went crazy about it.
Here's the one crazy.
There's petitions right now they're up to like,
I think last I saw it was 15,000 you know there's a cancer Wentz canceling it.
They have to be getting hurt by this because honestly Howard stern and opie and
Anthony,
that's pretty much,
you know,
fueling that channel I would imagine.
Do you know that?
For sure cause I don't know what they make their money off.
I have no idea.
I would just be guessing.
Well,
I would imagine that opie and Anthony has definitely a huge pie.
What's a great Chai?
Yeah,
it's a great show,
and by the way,
if it was on the Internet,
it would still be awesome if they just switched to the Internet.
It'd be huge.
I mean,
it might be a great opportunity for them if they mean they cancel Anthony if
they fire Anthony.
Just hope he's still under contract.
I mean,
how's that work?
What Ob said today is that him and Jim will be back Monday next Monday.
Well,
I said they might have,
they might be making it the opn gem show just based on contracts,
but what's interesting is,
is leading up to this is how much Opi has been talking about that he's done.
He's not going to sign a contract.
He does.
He wants to do a podcast.
He's done and it,
this whole timing of this is very interesting because sometimes that's how the
universe,
it's very interesting.
Very,
very interesting.
Yeah.
Wonder Man,
I hope they do a podcast.
Look,
the show's awesome.
It's funny.
Show to watch little Jimmy.
He's the funniest guy ever on radio.
Jim Norton is my favorite guy ever of all time on radio.
No question about it.
Consistently comes with the funny,
he's hilarious and he's smart.
He's well thought out.
He's a,
he's an interesting dude.
He's honest.
I really love Joey.
I think he's a hilarious comedian too.
He's so fun.
Plus he makes me feel,
I don't feel like so much of a per after hanging out with him,
like I thought my act at too many Dick Jokes.
Then went to see him and I
even told them that I go do it.
I had the best time that you freed me in a lot of ways because sometimes I go,
man,
I got so many Dick Jokes.
Why keep writing Dick Jokes?
His whole act was dick jokes from beginning to end and I loved it.
It was awesome.
I saw him at a cobb's Cobb's comedy club and the Austin,
not cubs
cap city Cap City Comedy Club in Austin.
Right.
Anthony is starting is a compound show this week though,
so that's going to be interesting.
Just to add to it.
I don't know how if he has a lawyer,
if he said he,
you know he was going to lawyer up if,
but what if he can talk about and what he can't talk about.
You know it's going to be interesting.
Well I'm pretty sure he could probably talk about the incident that he could
talk about.
No one can keep you from talking about a person attacking you.
How could they keep you from doing that?
Any person that could keep you from doing that is not a person want to be
associated with it.
They fire you for that.
Good.
Imagine someone keeping you from talking about you being attacked,
like your own personal experience.
How he expresses himself is entirely up to him.
I think we'll probably get a more balanced view of it now than when it happened.
You know?
I think he's probably going to take into consideration all the,
the heat and the bullshit and the time that's elapsed and the motions that have
relaxed and the tension that's relaxed,
the sting of the punches,
and he'll be able to look at it and give you a funny assessment of it,
but the,
the show just be better if they go on the Internet,
they can do whatever they want on your times.
You don't need anybody anymore.
You just don't it.
Yeah.
They can move anywhere they want.
You don't need anybody anymore.
It's,
it's silly.
It's like the amount of people that don't have iPods or iPhones or can't get
their phone to stream through their radio.
It's common almost everybody now it's really close,
you know?
I mean,
especially if you're commuting,
if you're getting on subways and shit like that,
and it's actually better than having some sort of a satellite that sends it to,
and you can get it whenever you want.
You can pause it.
You can listen whenever you want.
It's just a better medium,
you know?
And that,
don't get me wrong,
I have three cars that have a Sirius satellite radio.
I love it.
It's great.
I love the fact that I could flip through the shit and listen to new music.
I love that I can,
uh,
get on the classic Vinyl Station and listened to all classic rock cause I'm old
as fuck.
I'm old as fuck and I reminisce and listen to some Bob Seger.
I like it.
I like serious.
I'll keep it as a product,
but man,
you've got to realize what you're selling
it.
Music channels are definitely great.
Um,
for sure.
I haven't been to my cars also.
I just,
I know that the majority of what I listened to that was opie and Anthony and it
used to be Howard Stern,
but again,
you know,
mm.
It's just kind of not the same.
I think that,
um,
I think that they would be just as happy if not happier on the Internet.
I think they would do just as well,
if not better on the Internet.
I don't think there's any downside to this.
No one can stop you anymore.
They used to just be able to fire you and that was it.
They can't do that anymore because anybody could just go on with their cell
phone.
He could just start the other David Seaman show sitting here at chipotle lay
like this fucking government builds going on right now is basically bullshit.
That's basically what I do.
Yeah.
With a green screen using a cell phone in a green screen.
What if this would have happened if that series just instead took a different
route because you know they bitch about their studio and how horrible it is and
stuff like that.
What if they could just send it in like,
like kind of what Joe Rogan experience does do them.
We sit,
right,
right.
But what if,
would they still be as upset if he did all this Twitter rampage if he just had
to send in show where they had their own staff,
they own employees,
their own sponsors,
and they just send it in.
Well,
we're getting into a lot of what ifs now that we're not business people
obviously.
Right.
That's why we work together.
This,
you know,
we're,
I don't know what it would be like to be a part of a shareholder corporation
because they have shares.
They're responsible for a lot of shit.
Like they have to listen to a lot of people.
Man,
there's a lot of people involved.
When you have companies,
man,
anytime anything gets crazy and people start protesting and you got to act,
you've got to get out there and you've got to save this company as a
shareholder.
You know,
as the CEO,
uh,
like the guy that fucked the fucking Nba guy when they,
when they got rid of Donald Sterling and he's,
what's his name?
That fucking Ball Dracula looking dude,
that was so ridiculous on that podium.
I don't know.
Oh,
that was so ridiculous.
That goofy fuck.
That shit was so ridiculous.
We find him the maximum amount,
you know,
there,
that drives me crazy.
That whole story.
Like you got an old guy who's known for saying racial shit.
He tells his girlfriend she can fuck black guys.
Just don't take pictures with them and all you can focus on is the picture part.
She's,
he's letting her fuck black guys and you guys are going to find them.
Right?
2.5 million.
That's ridiculous.
The highest amount.
Oh it seems reasonable.
Yeah.
He told her don't take pictures of black guys.
What an asshole.
You can fuck them though.
If they leave that out,
the totally leave that out.
Why would he leave that out?
Because you can't,
you can't bring it up.
If that was [inaudible] that was you and you were the commissioner of the NBA
and you had to explain to people and you were like looking on the bright side.
He's allowing her to fuck black guys.
Right?
It's a,
yeah.
I,
I don't,
uh,
I don't know what to make of that one either.
Cause it seems like it goes back to what you were saying about how,
you know,
to get into an altercation or something.
Both people kind of need to be involved and you don't have to be an asshole and
say those things.
And if you're going to be an asshole and say those things,
you have to be aware that if you're also prominent and you own a fucking sports
team,
people are gonna listen to what you say more,
more so than somebody in a trailer saying the same thing on youtube.
Right?
Like if you post that in the youtube comment section,
you're not going to see a national uproar.
Especially if you're not that dude.
But if you're a billionaire and you own a sports team and you're always in the
public eye,
even if you're old,
that's not an excuse for saying racist shit.
You're absolutely right.
And I agree with you 100% but here's the,
but you're looking at this guy and this guy is being recorded against his will.
He has no idea is being recorded.
That's what he says.
So you're in a Mel Gibson possible scenario.
You're in a scenario where you're dating this girl and she,
I don't know,
she blackmail you.
I don't know what's going on.
I have no idea what the story is.
But I know that he did say he should have paid her off.
That is what he said.
That was one of his quotes that he should have paid her off and all this stuff
comes out and he,
he got he,
no one is saying that what she did is illegal.
No one's freaking out.
Everyone's paying attention to the fact that I think people are freaking out
that he comes across as an asshole to,
exactly.
I should not paid her off.
You should have said sorry like that to everybody is the kind of the character
of the old billionaire who represents everything that the average working person
kind of despises.
Right.
This old white guy is saying the shit that really is insensitive at best and I
can,
that's one of the situations where I can see that the media has just
manipulating people and it's just like bullshit anger that we're being
collectively drawn into,
but at the same time like,
well and the guy is kind of an asshole.
Like there's not 100% culpability in either direction.
Exactly.
It's just like what we've been talking about all day.
It's the same thing.
It's like there's not black and whites and everything's a lot.
Somebody like that.
I give less leeway for sure.
Like somebody like that.
Less leeway than a private citizen.
Wait a minute and he's a private citizen.
What do you mean billionaire?
And you own a sports team.
You have to be aware that you have an influence when you say things.
Whereas just some person on the sidewalk who says that most people are going to
be like,
well it's not my job cause you can't there.
See,
I can't see a way to justify recording someone and playing what they said,
no matter what it is.
If it's not a crime,
you know,
if it's as mildly offensive as that and it is offensive.
But he's an old guy and he's got this young girlfriend he's trying to fuck and
we're supposed to,
it's not a statement.
He's not making an affidavit.
He's,
he's trying to bang some chick and he's telling her to please you.
I don't care if you fuck it,
I'm just don't take pictures with them.
Okay.
And he's trying to get his freak on.
She records that.
I mean that's exactly what happened and that is exactly what he said happened.
He thought it was a private conversation between the two of them.
Is it despicable that he doesn't want her to take pictures of with black guys?
Cause he,
it makes him look bad.
Yeah.
It's not cool.
But he talks a her fuck them.
I mean that is,
that is a part of what he said.
Right.
And this isn't as simple as racism.
He said it's,
I don't care if you fuck them.
Like how racist is he?
He's letting her fuck black guys.
Well that's a low level racist for sure.
And the dizzy,
dizzy saying this in public because it's a big bold statement on Twitter.
Like Anthony.
No,
no.
He's in the confines of his own home and he's trying to get laid.
You're going to try and he was probably had a couple of drinks in him too.
You're going to hold the guy to that publicly.
Yeah.
Is he an asshole?
Yes.
But he's not trying to hurt feelings.
He's not trying to spread hate.
I mean he just trying to get laid.
Yeah.
It seems to me that the intent of what you're saying,
like the context and the intent are pretty critical when you're released
something like that and you get angry and find someone for something like that.
That was a knee jerk reaction or response that they took regardless of whether
the guy is an asshole.
I,
I've heard both ways of her more than he is.
Then he isn't,
who knows?
I don't know,
but I don't like it.
I don't think it's cool.
I don't think it's cool that you take this all the asshole and do that to him
and I think it's going to wind up selling the clippers for like a fucking
trillion dollars and he's going to profit off of it anyway.
Yeah.
And there's reports that he's just going crazy and that's also as taking
something that you,
like you said,
private,
you know in that in your own house,
like it that's complete.
It should be a hunt.
It is 100% illegal.
Like I shouldn't have to worry about you taking all my texts and all my stuff
out of my phone and then putting it online.
Why are you being fine tuned a half million dollars if a crime wasn't committed.
Right,
exactly.
You're not the government.
Why are you finding somebody that much money?
It's one thing if it's like we're in a dock,
your pay for a week,
that's not chump change.
I don't understand he's a billionaire,
but you're enforcing something with a lot of weight there.
I couldn't agree more and I also think that it's a situation that merits a
serious conversation.
May merits serious conversation about race,
about context,
about privacy.
It merits that would,
it doesn't matter if some guy giving some canned speech where he's got this
righteous indignation in his voice,
we are going to find him the maximum amount and he's basically running for
president or something.
He's got that fake politician thing going on was giving this speech totally
disingenuous.
The whole thing is goofy.
Like you get a flat or you're not paying attention to the whole recording while
you focus on the one part.
Don't take pictures of black guys.
They have their freaks.
He's letting her fuck guys like this is not a normal dude and he's at home in
his bedroom.
What is this real am I,
is this a real world where you just find him two and a half million dollars from
that?
You guys are assholes.
The whole thing is an asshole organization will,
you should all do is sit down and have a conversation.
Everybody sit down and you go,
what happened here?
And he gets a chance to say,
well,
I was hanging out with this chick and she,
I buy Ferrari's and shit.
I got a fat pen house for her.
She's my Goomada.
I got her on the side.
But uh,
every,
you know,
she fucks it all the black guys but just takes pictures and my friends sticking
with my face mocking me.
So I told her,
don't take pictures of black guys.
Please.
What would you really freak out if someone said that?
He'd be like,
well that's an unfortunate relationship for that poor old billionaire and sort
of an unfortunate,
even more unfortunate relationship for that lovely young lady who has such low
self esteem that she needs this old man.
To pay for her sex and buy her things.
And that's how she gets by,
by hustling.
And in the meantime she hangs out with all these black guys,
whatever,
man,
what do you give a fuck?
This is goofy is a goofy thing for you to be taken up my CNN with over and over
and over again,
playing it back and forth and those sorts of details of the Donald Sterling
tapes emerge.
He didn't want him.
Come on,
come on.
Silly.
It's fucking,
it's,
it's a nonissue.
He's not an evil person.
He's not Hitler.
He didn't even say a racial slur.
North Korea
people are being sent to concentration camps.
CNN has zero interest in
a really covering that.
You know that the depictions,
the illustrated depictions that,
that one guy who escaped from the camp,
you've ever seen?
That one.
The guy was Kate from the prison camp was showing the various stages.
Brian,
he pulled out.
Pull that up cause you could see it.
You could walk,
you could look at the actual images.
Yeah.
I don't think I've seen it,
but sounds pretty gross.
It's going to freak you the fuck out.
It's a guy who escaped from this,
you know,
essentially slave camp.
The slave prison.
Yeah.
They had like hundreds of thousands of people there who are in straight up
concentration camp.
People are born there man.
Cause people are born in these camps.
I mean it's,
it's an,
it's unbelievably heartbreaking when you hear these stories.
And one guy escaped and he had been,
I think it's the same guy.
He had been born there.
He grew up there.
He had no idea what life outside the camps was.
And he started explaining all the various aspects of torture.
Um,
w what level of deterioration they would judge prisoners out and it's complete
Nazi Germany type shit.
And it's going on in 2014.
Right now.
It's just like Nazi Germany stuff.
I mean it's,
I don't know how they single out the prisoners,
what they're in there for or why that is political dissent.
Is it crime?
Well,
I don't know what it is,
but they've,
what if,
when they,
once I've decided this is the enemy,
this is us,
right,
is the good,
they don't have to do anything over there.
He,
uh,
I think sent like all of his girlfriend's family or his ex girlfriend's family
to one of the camps or some shit.
Like,
it's crazy he did.
He's like Kim Jong,
whatever.
I forget the guy's name.
Kim Jong Gun.
Just Google that and like ex girlfriend.
Oh God.
Well,
I know he did that one girlfriend,
he killed his uncle.
Right?
He executed his uncle.
He's a crazy dude.
So anyway,
my point with that is that shows you that the whole media moral equivalency
thing is bullshit.
They focus on things as if it's a more outrage.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I could see how this is offensive,
but what about that?
What about everything else happening in the world?
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
It's just,
I couldn't even imagine living in a place like North Korea.
I mean,
it's not even,
will you put your head in that place where you get to bring up whatever the
thing is?
Yeah.
Brian's is trying to find it.
Soon as you find is the search terms that I'm not finding it.
Did you write North Korea escape pictures?
North Korea escape pictures?
He,
um,
he drew them all.
Um,
it's,
it's really dark shit,
man.
He drew all these images of,
do you know what it is?
You know what I'm talking about?
I didn't find it.
Um,
prisoner.
Yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
Man.
Or escaped in North Korea prison.
This is it.
So this guy,
he,
he drew these depictions of like how malnourished people would be.
Well,
how they would treat them.
Um,
how they would treat them based on what they weighed,
what jobs he would give them up until the moment when they died.
You know,
unreal stuff.
Yeah.
It's insane.
Like,
look at this.
This guy's killing babies.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Dude,
this is,
it's dark and it's going on right now.
I mean,
it's confirmed.
it's a scary place when you know that the guy who's the head of Korea right now,
someone was trying to make coup against him.
He had him assassinated and he had his son's assassinated because he thought his
sons would one day tried to seek revenge.
He has sons killed.
And then he had his wife and he gave his wife a res.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I gave her like a better position in a race,
like the whole situation has completely gangster.
Could you imagine the guy kills your sons and then gives you some sort of a new
job?
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
it seems normal.
Well,
did they treat him almost as like a God?
Right.
So it's a little bit different.
They war ship everything he does.
I think it's just straight fear,
you know?
I don't know.
That's probably part of it also.
Do you know that when,
when his father died,
if people didn't cry convincingly enough,
they got like six month terms.
Wow.
2014 it's going on right now.
Happening
completely crazy.
I can't see why the Twitter storm can't focus on that asshole for a little bit.
Make his life difficult.
What can you do?
Send them pizzas.
Much bankrupt them until the US invades him.
Well,
the problem is they,
they'll take it,
they'll be fine.
There's enough resources that they'll be fine.
People will starve to death.
I mean,
look what they're doing to these people in these prisoner camps.
Fucking unbelievably terrifying shit,
man.
That can happen,
that the world can vary so much.
That's what's scary is it?
Cause it gives us the possibility of that happening here.
You start thinking like that.
Well that's why I'm so against government overreach cause it doesn't start all
at once.
And then at one point that was a new thing for them.
Like,
Oh I guess we got this now.
Right.
And then you grow up and that's just normalcy even though it's completely insane
to everybody else.
That's what this surveillance stuff is,
is complete insanity.
And everybody in Europe is pissed off about it.
And here things have been kind of normalized and it's like,
well it has kept us safe.
And the new thing that came out I think in the Washington Post or the times is
about how nine out of 10 people that they're grabbing the photos and videos and
stuff of our,
not even the targets,
they're just people being incidentally sucked up.
But when they say like,
we're incidentally grabbing their data,
it means like really intimate stuff,
like the video conversations that people have had with their partners or just
being stored in databases.
And,
uh,
that's the beginning of,
and there was another report that they might be collecting baby photos.
The NSA might be archiving people's baby photos.
That's the beginning of not tomorrow,
but maybe in 50 years for sure.
Some shit like that because that's how it starts right there.
It's like you get to stage one,
maybe we don't even see stage two in our lifetimes.
But to give people you don't know that kind of power is insane,
right?
And if things go bad,
that's when you justify stage two things are fine now.
But look what if a Katrina type situation happened?
One of the things that every leader,
every great military leader knows is that you must capitalize on opportunities.
And when a tragedy takes place,
it's not just a tragedy,
but it's also an opportunity for more control.
And it's one of the things that classically people have done throughout time and
in us history,
it's very easy to map.
And it's one of the reasons why conspiracy theories are so rampant when it comes
to big crimes like Oklahoma City is because you see a ramp up of the laws
afterwards.
And a lot of people think,
well,
this was a false flag event.
It was used to justify the ramping off of laws and now they have more control.
Whether or not it was or wasn't.
The point being every time there is some sort of an incident where things go
bad,
whoever is a power hungry fuckhead tried to take more control as if it would've
protected them from that situation.
Whether it's the Oklahoma thing,
whether it's nine 11 if nine 11 was just an attack and it wasn't just some
nefarious plot.
I mean it was just some nefarious plot from some overseas people and had nothing
to do with the United States government.
It doesn't matter.
The United States government still capitalizing.
I think that's absolutely vin.
That's absolutely what I believe happened by the way,
is that there was not a,
it was not an inside job.
It was an opportunity to stick thing afterwards where,
Oh,
this fell in our lap.
We're going to capitalize on it to the maximum amount possible,
which is what they did.
The neoconservatives under Bush got us into two wars that arguably we didn't
need to be in it at all.
What's a classic military.
Yeah,
and introduced all these laws that really I think shut down like a lot of the
innovation we're seeing now is people speaking freely,
podcast,
you know,
TV shows where people are really speaking their minds.
All that Shit Kinda went on ice during the Bush administration.
Like,
I hate to be like a Bush hater,
but I noticed because I was in high school at the time during the Bush
administration,
I was in high school when nine 11 happened and I noticed that the kind of death
of vitality and like people were afraid to be,
you don't want to sound like an asshole,
right?
Like everybody was for the Iraq war.
And if you're like,
I don't know,
like should we go in there?
People just go nine 11 have you forgotten?
And I'm like,
I'm not sure how the two are connected.
Really.
Like I'm not sure why.
And some people were saying the same thing,
but the overriding thing was you don't want to be like against the country at
this important time.
And that bullshit lasted for a decade where I'm sure a lot of terrible things
happen that we don't even know about yet and might not know about for awhile.
And only now are we starting to see like kind of the flowering of independent
thought that probably would have happened 10 fucking years ago if it weren't for
nine 11 and if it weren't for that crackdown cause we have the internet,
we were on the path and I feel like all this stuff now,
podcasting could have been in 2004
it might have been,
but the technology wasn't there yet as far as like the ability to broadcast.
That's true.
The broad broad band wasn't there yet,
but just that movement of people speaking their minds would have started sooner.
And there was fear like a lot of people were afraid and there are no fly list.
That was a serious thing for awhile.
People would say you,
oh don't fuck around.
You're gonna have the no fly list
now.
It was like,
it was abused.
Yeah.
I mean it was abused by people that they were,
they were going after consenting journalism or a dissenting,
a journalist,
Laura podiatrists who,
uh,
did that New York Times story about William Binney and she's done some other
important stuff since then.
She claims that every time she goes to an airport,
she gets the full thing because they want to show her like,
keep an eye.
We're keeping an eye on you.
So well they just throw,
all they have to do is throw you on a list.
The people that are working,
they're giving him the f the frisking.
I mean,
they're not showing her shit.
They're just working conveyor belt.
Yeah.
They're making x amount per hour.
They're putting in their time waiting for that Buzzer to rank so they can get
the fuck out of there.
But someone,
all they had to do is put her on a list.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
that conveyor belt idea of like,
once the order has been given,
then it's somebody just doing their job.
Yeah.
That's why so much bad stuff in the world is happening right now.
Like this is what I research all day.
I'm kind of a obviously crazy,
but uh,
the military to about that,
the military industrial complex is clearly real.
It's a real thing.
It's an economic force where people get employed by companies that pay them way
more than they should be paid for.
What they're doing,
right?
So you get paid $200,000 to design the next drone.
Any other job at your age,
you'd be lucky to make $40,000 so you go into this new world where you don't
really belong and this is what happened is snowed in.
From what you know,
it seems like this young guy gets into this world where he's making far more
money than he would otherwise.
All you have to do is buy in.
All you have to do is I can see this,
I can see spying on everybody constantly cause it is keeping us safe and I'm
making a lot of money.
And if you're the drone designer,
drone designer,
I can see this.
So from your little perspective,
it's not all that bad and you branch out,
you zoom out far enough and you see that we're a society that is basically run
by an avatar government that starts or at least provokes wars for its own
benefit and for very cynical reasons that have nothing to do with what they tell
us on TV.
And from there you go,
I can't stop the conveyor belt.
Nobody can,
you know,
you can send out 10,000 retweets are a million petitions that does not stop the
conveyor belt because at the end of the day,
that person who's doing whatever they're doing spying on you or frisking you,
they're like,
well,
I'm not going to be unemployed.
Like I understand what you're saying,
semen on the podcast and I understand what,
uh,
you know,
the eff says,
I'm not going to sit at home without a paycheck.
I'd rather just be sifting through people's emails.
And obviously most people make that choice.
That's a problem with human nature,
I guess is people need money to pay their rent.
And,
um,
the only solution is to actually change that economic structure.
Like by,
by military industrial complex.
That's old paradigm shit.
Country to country warfare is over.
It's on its way out cause we're starting to move toward a different kind of
system and um,
that's,
it's cool for me to watch because it's actually happening.
Like what I'm talking about is not something out in the clouds.
It's already well underway.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a strange time in that their ability to do what they're doing,
their ability to spy on people,
their ability to influence people,
their ability to have control over the populous with these,
uh,
these tools of surveillance is coinciding with people's ability to communicate
their,
their uh,
being upset about it.
This is,
this is a weird time because in the sixties and seventies when all that
Watergate shit was going down,
what,
what voice did a regular person could have,
you could hope,
you would just hope that the Washington Post would publish an op Ed.
Do you agree with,
and that's pretty much the extent of your power.
When Kennedy was assassinated,
what,
what happened?
Well,
who taught we,
how did the people get their thoughts and imagine if there was an Alex Jones
back there back then when the real platform,
how insane that would have been.
Oh my God,
they would've killed him quick.
If Alex Jones lived in 1963 they would have killed the shit out of him.
Do you imagine?
They were probably was about 20 Alex Jones at the time,
but what could they have done though?
That's the point.
Like Alex Jones has a real radio show that he does on the Internet.
His youtube videos,
giant youtube channel.
He has a regular radio show mean what could a god have done in 1963 the answer
is nothing.
Yeah,
but no,
he's also a couple other assholes can't get laid.
I wonder if they did.
How many people we think
my uncle used to do it all the time and it was so creepy and be like,
Hey,
want to talk to somebody?
And you'd be like talking like,
oh,
they're in Russian hours.
Yeah,
I knew one dude who did it,
but that's it.
One.
I mean,
it wasn't like,
it was like everybody had a radio in their house,
right.
Growing up,
it basically,
everybody had a TV.
If you didn't have a TV,
you were a Weirdo.
Bobby just family doesn't believe in TV.
That's like people who don't have internet.
If somebody says they don't have Internet,
I'm like,
I don't understand that at all.
Why would you do that?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I don't want to get caught up in it.
How about grown some fucking discipline.
You joining the human race.
Like if you don't have the internet,
you don't know what's happening.
Oh,
I don't know how to get online.
You don't win silly.
Fuck it.
This is the,
this is the time to voice your opinions on things.
This is the time to speak up
and it's the top.
Well,
it's the time to see that this old thing is luckily ending.
Like I think some people are still caught up in the,
um,
the police brutality outrageous that you see on the homepage of reddit every day
and that people are always tweeting.
That stuff's real.
And I understand why people are pissed.
And I 100% think it's the right move to shame the shit out of those people.
And always like have that,
that fire going.
But that's not the solution.
The solution is that economics are gradually shifting away from the military
industrial thing and we're shifting into a different economic model and that
will end this stuff like the spying and the drones and the police brutality.
That's what ends it.
Cause you just don't have as many cops and the cops you do have are more locally
financed.
And it's kind of the way it was and some kind of mad men utopia that probably
never existed.
It was a hell of a lot better than what we have right now.
Yeah.
Um,
what do you think is going to happen,
do you think,
is this a war right now where technology and the,
that the average person has to information is at odds with this gigantic
Neolithic Group of corporations,
corporations that are sort of combining forces to try to slow down the Internet?
Is this a battle of good and evil?
Fucking Internet control net neutrality and regulations?
I want your Isp,
you little fuck,
give me your eyes be number,
whether it's just stopping this tide is transcendence
good versus evil because then you fall into the US versus the outrage kind of
thing.
I just look at the data and I,
that's what I've tried to do with as many aspects of my life as possible is
emotion is fine because after you see the data you get emotional.
That's 100% fine,
but you shouldn't be deriving your conclusion from the emotion.
And what I see is that a lot of this stuff is going to end just essentially
ByDesign.
So by design meaning that as innovation increases,
people are not going to tolerate it anymore.
Better technology or better technologies take off.
I mean the reason why we're having this conversation is not because some Ben
Franklin was like within 200 something years we will have podcasts.
It's because gradual technological innovation comes along and it took probably a
million things before this to get to this point.
And now that you're here,
it doesn't take you any more effort to put out a podcast cause it's all built.
And it's the same thing with,
if you look at the development of travel,
people used to get around by foot,
then it was carriage is like Oregon trail type shit where if you had to go from
New York to California you might not make it now it's a flight that costs $250
and it takes like five hours.
And the same thing is happening with the economy where we're getting away from
old kind of superstitious technology and entering the age of science,
like science is now being applied to economics and to money.
And that's going to change some of the worst aspects of society.
For sure.
Like if anything I've researched,
this is the one that most convinced will not come true,
but it's already happening around us.
And what,
what makes you so positive that it's going to happen again?
Because it already is,
it's just in the early phases.
Like,
if you look at,
uh,
the B word,
you look at Bitcoin as an eight Jews call it the be yeah,
because I was debating whether to even talk about bitcoin this time because
people get so into it.
Uh,
it's like an,
it's because it's money.
People get emotional about money,
you know,
and it's,
they get into it in a negative way.
You mean?
Um,
no,
just I don't want to be known as the bitcoin person because that's not the
totality of me.
Right?
Like I think you should worry about that.
Okay.
Well anyway,
I'm going to be the bit,
all right,
good.
I just don't want it because call people are still like,
you're a great advocate for bitcoin.
I'm like,
I'm not trying to be like,
I'm trying to report on an important shift in society,
which,
so anyway,
bitcoin is worth $8 billion.
Is it really?
Four years?
Yeah.
Four years ago it was worth like nothing.
Like one guy traded 10,000 bitcoins on a discussion forum in exchange for
somebody to order him a pizza and pay for it.
And now those 10,000 bitcoins are worth like six point something million.
So something is happening in society,
something's happening in society where we're saying like,
oh,
we can create money without governments doing it for us.
And that's a very simple shift.
It's not a big deal.
People have already accepted at Earl's.
Bitcoin wouldn't be around.
And if you take that little choice out to its logical conclusion,
it's going to be a drastically different world in 10 20,
30 years,
it's going to be a different world and two years,
no doubt about it.
I mean,
I think that we're seeing this now or people are starting to get paid in
Bitcoin,
like who did who,
there was a story recently about someone getting paid in Bitcoin.
Well,
John Fitch got paid and in Nautilus coin,
which is,
uh,
an alt coin,
so,
and he got paid in that for his last fight,
right?
Yeah.
Nautilus coin.
He got paid,
I think it was 20,000 Nautilus coin and then some people contributed on top of
that.
Wow.
And it ended up on NBC.
Like this weekend's fight.
He was wearing boxers that have their logo all over it and that was done in
completely over the Internet.
I watched the deal go down on Twitter because he and Brian Kelly interacted
publicly and that's pretty cool because if you think about like what,
what did we use money for?
One of the things is sponsoring events,
like banks own stadiums.
That's going to change.
It's going to be bitcoin stadium and you know,
doggy coin,
uh,
whatever I said,
Doge coin or doggy coin.
I've tried both and I get,
I get called out either way.
I prefer to say Doge coin because it sounds a little bit more sophisticated and
doggy coin.
Yeah.
What does it stand for?
It's,
it's an Internet meme.
A that that dog with a stupid face,
a the Sheba,
whatever that breed is.
How famous she would he know.
Yeah.
Is that a she,
she blew it up.
He's got the main output.
So in front of anything you want to say,
basically like so rich,
so,
so wow.
You know,
such whoa.
So that's where Doge coin came and emerged as a novelty coin and then got so
much transaction volume that people started.
Some people started to take it seriously.
It's so strange with stuff like that happens,
isn't it?
It's like what makes a bitcoin just take take off other than the great design,
but what?
What makes it bit coin?
What makes a Doge coin that makes,
that's what's so exciting about it now point is human psychology,
like that's the reason why the $50 bill in your pocket is a $50 bill and not the
sheet of paper,
right?
It's purely psychology.
You see the pyramid on the back,
you see the dude on the front,
that's money to you.
Totally enough.
People around the world have said that,
you know,
bitcoin and even some people have said that Doge coin,
like,
you know what?
This is money to me,
I understand that it took somebody time to make and that it can't be
counterfeit.
Those are really the two biggest properties of any of these coins is they're
hard to make and you can't counterfeit them,
period.
So when you get that thing going,
you trade it back and forth over time.
Some people lose their password.
So over time the amount is reducing.
I'm talking about bit coin,
not Dutch coin because there are too many dose coins,
but bitcoin you're using it constantly.
So the amount is being reduced over time just through through usage.
But unlike a government currency where people uh,
know that more money will be printed,
this is the opposite.
Like we,
oh we know that only so much is going to be printed over time and then that's it
ever.
So fascinating.
And so what might happen is some kind of weird feeding frenzy where everybody
gets into it at once because increasing values create one of the strongest
network effects that we know of is people like you think about how fast Facebook
took off.
That was just people like,
oh,
it's cool that I can casually spy on my friends that I'm in class with.
This is,
oh,
I now have complete control over my own money.
And it's appreciating,
you know,
at a certain rate that beats anything that of traditional bank can offer.
The problem is that these things come and go so frequently that people don't
want to dip their fingers or their feet in the water thinking that it might be
the next AOL.
Right.
You know,
that might be the first one,
the first one,
and then they really get it locked down to what we all agree to a,
you know,
elder coin or whatever the fuck we're going to call it,
five years from now or two years from now.
I'm going to share my strategy and I absolutely do not want anybody to think
that this is like what you should do.
This is just what I've done so people can understand like,
you know,
this is what I believe is a good thing to do for me,
not for anybody else.
Uh,
I agree with you 100%.
I'm only convinced that this currency thing will take off.
I'm not even 100% convinced that bitcoin will make it because the bitcoin
foundation has been doing some really stupid fucked up things.
Like what?
Well,
they appointed a guy who has a really checkered past and I feel like I
should not have been,
you know,
a part of that organization.
But point is,
can you,
do you mind saying like,
what is this checkered past?
Like,
wait,
can you say checkered past?
You can Google it.
It's too serious that,
I don't even want to say it,
but it's really bad.
Bad allegation of violence stuff.
Uh,
like,
like molestation type stuff.
And uh,
this,
I,
I think if you Google this,
it might be public.
It doesn't really matter.
But uh,
might be now.
Anyway,
the point is that foundation I feel like has made some bad moves.
And aside from that,
it's the first one.
So if you look at like compuserve,
they probably want a lot of battles.
We're not using fucking compuserve to connect to the Internet,
right?
So I'm only convinced that the technology will win,
not that bitcoin will win.
So what I do is I own a little bit of Bitcoin and again,
I'm not rich,
so this is like a reasonable person money.
I own a little bit of bitcoin and I also in a little bit of the three or four
currencies after bitcoin that show the most promise and I own enough of each one
that should they come in and become the next bitcoin or the next light coin,
I'll be really satisfied.
But if they don't come in,
it's not the end of the world.
And what I'm doing is when one currency doesn't do anything new for two months
or something better comes out,
I shift the money into that one.
So my,
my ideas,
however long this process takes of us going digital to new kinds of money,
which is happening all be in at least one of the ones that does well.
And we'll just try to keep,
I think at this point they're already mature brands that will take off.
Do you ever see a point where,
you know how you'd go to the airport and you see the government,
uh,
currency exchange where it's like Australian dollar is Mexican pesos and it has
all the things like what the rates are,
you know,
those things they have at the airport.
We can exchange your money.
Do you ever think it's going to come a point where there's so many accepted
currencies that we have that on everything.
Like this is what every price is like,
it's worth this much of that.
And it's a fluctuating thing.
It's on a uh,
like a like,
you know,
some sort of a stock market,
sort of a ticker tape type of thing where it flux because it does fluctuate on a
daily basis.
I have some bitcoin.
It's interesting to watch it go up and down.
Sometimes it's,
it's a big jump and sometimes it's a big drop.
What you just mentioned already exists basically like the alt market will blow
your mind.
If you go on a,
you can bring up,
um,
it'll,
it'll blow the mind as far as like your ability to purchase things.
No,
just how many currencies are trading against each other.
It really is exactly like that foreign exchange board at the airport.
Except way more complex.
Like if you go on mint pal,
there are a range of currencies that you probably and I have not even heard of
and they're trading against bitcoin.
And in some cases trading against other currencies,
like there are currencies now that don't even really trade against bitcoin
because they're like two steps removed from that.
How would it be possible that all these could exist and you could purchase items
from it from with them?
Rather like say if you want to get a case of this delicious sea two oh coconut
oil,
this is not a paid sponsor.
This is not a plug.
There's not like an unfair plug that I put in there.
But if you wanted to buy a case of this and would they have to have like a bunch
of deer,
like it's worth to doge coins,
it's worth 1.9 bit.
You know what I mean?
Could you have,
you're not,
you might just be a currency exchange programs.
It probably went program.
They just like an APP.
The math for it,
like an APP.
So you would have to the everybody that works in a store,
like you'd have to run a price.
Well,
it's what's interesting is since this is software and not government issued
currencies,
this stuff can happen instantly.
You don't need to be like,
oh,
we need to check in with the government of Argentina and make sure they're cool
with this.
It just happens immediately.
So there are already services being built that are pretty much what you're
thinking of.
Like they want to work on universal wallets where you don't have to think about
what currency you're sending,
you're just sending somebody value.
So if I want to send you $10 worth of internet value,
I could do it.
I don't have to even know what currency it is as long as it's a mutually agreed
amount of money.
Right.
If it could be a mutually agreed upon number,
like instead of saying this is a hundred bitcoins,
it could just be this is a hundred well 100 and Bitcoin is 98 a hundred and Doge
coin is one oh one you know what I mean?
Like whatever the number is,
the value number,
you entered into an app and it will read out what it is and whatever currency
you choose to use.
And since it's all going to be done online and it's all sort of,
you know,
in hard drives in the in space,
you could kind of like have as many of them as you want it.
It's not like if you had a cash register and you're at a store and some asshole
comes in
with Canadian money and he wants Australia and change,
like pitch,
get the fuck out of here.
You're crazy.
I don't have Australian money.
But if you are digitally connected and you service 20 major coin,
you know,
whatever you would call them,
programs,
what would you call them?
Uh,
people call him our ses,
I think actually,
I mean it's more software than currency,
but everybody calls it a currency and a,
if you look at um,
Hollywood boulevard,
they have some of those foreign exchange stands also.
There are a couple of stores you walk in,
you trade your,
if you're a Chinese tourists,
you trade your won for US dollars.
Then you can shop at,
you know,
the shops there.
That step is going to go away,
not just on Hollywood boulevard,
all over the world.
You think about how cool that is that now you can travel to any country,
walk into their malls and just pay with a mutually agreed upon currency.
It seems inevitable doesn't it sort of like we looked at the Internet in 1993 is
like wow,
this is kind of cool thing that you're,
well it didn't even seem like it was free.
It was the internet because it was going through the line,
the phone line.
It was just a shitty version of the TV that couldn't play movies.
That's what's happening now.
Some of these people are Weirdos,
some of this stuff and you're like Doge coin,
what the fuck is this?
But like out of that you're starting to see the very beginnings of a,
one of the companies I've been covering is a company that does this like
legitimately as a product.
Like they have I think 16 or 17 employees and they build currencies.
That's what they do.
They build currencies and if they haven't built it,
they find ones that are taking off and support them and mind them and make money
off of them and see.
You're starting to see like a more professional kind of environment where
there's still a lot of experimentation,
but it's starting to be like this is serious business and I think it was
Citibank.
So that digital currency by 2020 is going to be like a $10 trillion industry or
something insane.
And we got to get from there to here,
from here to there and we're already at the year 2014.
So a lot of money gets made over the next six years.
A lot of money gets lost and a lot of new stuff gets created that we can't even
think of yet.
I totally could see it.
I totally didn't see it.
It seems like the people that are all,
uh,
hedging their bets now and it's almost like they know something's going to
happen.
Like they see this bubbling on the surface like a volcano's about to rob,
but they can't figure out which were,
where's the mainstream going to come out of it?
It's going to be here.
Is it going to be here?
This is,
this is the next Internet,
this is the next thing.
It absolutely is.
And it's going to be fucked.
Uh,
people,
I think by now people listen to your show.
Sort of know my track record.
I wasn't wrong about drones,
I wasn't wrong about the NSA really.
And this one,
you're on about a lot of shit.
This is going to be big.
And it's,
uh,
what's called a black swan event and people aren't familiar with black swan
event is the thing like the financial crisis in oh eight,
that takes everybody spice surprise and changes everything.
And this is the same deal.
It's like now we have an airplane before we did it.
What do we do with this airplane?
Oh,
let's start.
Let's try to fly to London.
And before you know it,
you have commercial air flight.
That's what's going to happen here.
As people are experimenting.
And before you know it,
there's no more euro dollar.
There's just bitcoin and whatever else.
We as a people,
as a species is money.
And here's where it gets really cool.
And then I'll shut up about this.
But,
uh,
um,
somebody on the Reddit bitcoin a category,
they're subreddit,
uh,
posted this thing about how if you really think about what's happening,
people are making money from these coins because they have to mine them,
which takes energy.
You're getting your utility bill goes up.
When you're mining these coins,
you notice the difference.
And uh,
so what people are doing regardless of language,
is deciding that I can transfer some of my energy for money,
for actual money that I can use to buy anything else in this physical world.
So now you have a globally competitive,
a market for energy that will be created as a result.
You'll have entrepreneurs who aren't interested in creating coins.
They're interested in how do I get energy as cheaply as possible.
So you'll see solar fields in the deserts in Africa,
maybe to fuel a mine for a cryptocurrency.
So it's gonna.
What it's gonna do is incentivize a lot of us to find cheaper energy no matter
what.
So you're going to see all this innovation where the energy industry has to get
cheaper and cheaper because we have to continue mining these currencies.
Fuck.
Which is pretty crazy to think about.
So it's a technology that by design is going to make us,
I'm using all these bullshit terms like better,
but we're going to care more about cheap energy than we do now,
which I see as a good thing and we're going to care more about what does my
purchasing power mean.
Did I really agree that this has value?
And that's what's so cool about all this stuff is that nobody's forcing anybody
to do anything.
It's all voluntary
and it's all happening while marijuana is becoming illegal or becoming legal,
rather,
it's all happening on marijuana is legal in Colorado.
They just,
I just tweeted something today about the statistics from Colorado that they're
getting back from as far as crime and revenue,
more revenue than ever before.
More revenue than even projected and less crime.
Yup.
Cause you were locking up poor tourists and college kids and now it's no longer
a crime.
So you're making money off it.
Shit,
loads one and New York legalize it.
Brian who talk about this because I got it.
Yeah.
New York to today legalized medical marijuana.
Um,
it's becoming the state to permit this use a Monday and said,
hey,
I found that video though a that you were talking about earlier about you come
at me Bro.
Oh,
uh,
yeah.
It's uh,
do you even lift bro?
Is that the one?
Yeah.
Let's see what this is.
Um,
but I don't know that medical marijuana thing though in New York is a,
I don't think it's,
it's like legit medical marijuana.
It's probably not going to be like the California.
I just got my license renewed yesterday and it was the first time where it
actually was a little bit harder than normal.
And I don't know if it was just the doctor because the doctor was like this old
doctor and you walk in and you guys,
all right.
What,
why do you need medical marijuana and use,
I used to be able to just say it eases me with stress.
I,
it helps me go to sleep at night.
Uh,
it helps me eat.
And what's funny is those things are true.
Like you would probably be taking Xanax or a sleeping pill if you weren't using
weeds.
So when people say like,
Oh,
I'm a medical marijuana patient,
like it actually is medicine.
Right?
But he came at me like,
that's not a medical medical reason.
And I'm like,
well,
I use it to sleep.
That's not a medical reason.
Uh,
I get it for stress.
That's not magic.
My inquiry.
Then I finally said,
headache.
It goes,
all right,
that's a medical reason.
And then he like signed the paper.
Uh,
but my friend that was with this guy sounds like the grand Terino of like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Why would you do that?
Why would you go to there?
Go to Idleman.
What would you go anywhere else?
A lot of money.
He's um,
you know,
he went to jail though.
He gets my props because he went to jail.
He was like one of the pioneers,
but 220 versus 200.
It's less than that.
But I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
But that's what you get.
You get some fucking fuck off script a joint,
then you're not going to go to jail.
Decriminalized in California a long time.
I know.
All those sorts of Niagara decriminalized it.
The worst you can get is like a ticket and get like a ticket.
If they catch you smoking it and they
point out the legalization thing cause that's happening simultaneously and is
every bit is important.
Like yes,
because it's creating entrepreneurs and creating revenue by people that smoke
pot.
It's a completely different ethic.
It's going to even amber Lyon,
our mutual friend,
uh,
his committed,
you know,
pretty much her professional time right now to promoting this idea of a medical
uses for psychedelics,
which is,
it was recently in slate.
Like it seems like the whole kind of mainstream consciousness is coming around
to this idea that well shit,
if it works and we're starting to have that attitude towards everything.
Like bitcoin sounds crazy,
but if it works and the fees are lower,
why not?
And yeah,
it's the same with this.
Like if people can be more relaxed and maybe have some personal insights,
why not?
We should give out ambers websites,
reset.me,
reset dot Emmy and it's a new website that she created entirely based on the
idea of resetting consciousness through psychedelics.
And all the latest research and news on psychedelics.
She wants it to be like the Huffington post for psychedelics.
She went hogwild I found that I just went full on hog.
She went full hog.
She's awesome video that he was talking about earlier.
That do you even lift bro?
Okay,
well good.
So hold on a second.
We just want to talk about amber because she's,
uh,
she's this new website is very important for her.
She,
um,
she kind of was really,
she talked about it on the podcast.
She was really like down in the dumps and very bummed out about her situation.
The leaving CNN and decided to just take a trip down to the jungle and went to,
well she was working in the,
she was working in the factory and finally saw how the sausage is made.
Exactly.
And for,
I mean I used to,
I still consider myself a journalist and it is a depressing moment when you
realize like,
this is fucked.
Yeah.
But you don't work for anybody doing it.
I don't work for that.
But kind of journalist,
you know,
and the best kind of journalist is to kind of journalists that she saw that from
within CNN.
I just see that from outside.
I'm like,
oh,
these people are all fucked up.
But she got to see that from the inside,
which has got a fascinating,
well,
fascinating,
but also depressing because how hard do you have to work to get to CNN?
Yeah,
very hard.
I mean,
look in,
they find out you're not playing ball.
He does.
A lot of people have these idealized visions of what they're going to be able to
accomplish as a journalist,
you know,
I'm going to be the next guy who breaks the big story,
the next girl who takes down the evil regime.
And then you get over and you film the evil regime when you have all this
evidence and your risk your life,
and it gets really crazy and herring and get back to the states and they put out
an info piece,
like an infotainment infomercial piece of the city and you're like,
Whoa,
how come you didn't have a sniper footage?
Why?
Where's the sniper footage?
Where's the people dying?
Where's the like what are you guys doing here?
What's going on here?
You just made up fluff piece.
We have the best Starbucks if anywhere in the Middle East.
Started
her new site is great though.
She spent a lot of time on it and a lot of effort.
Uh,
so um,
just just to check it out for something that's interesting to go to reset.me
lots of cool stuff on there too.
Like I said,
she wants it to be the Huffington post of psychedelics.
So what were you saying about um,
the do lift bro?
I just find that video that we had brought up earlier,
they were going to talk to the Russian guy.
He does pranking a big giant.
People ask them if they lift.
Is this old or new?
It's like a year or two old surprise.
You guys haven't seen it but he does new stuff.
He's a,
this is him.
He's going to,
why won't take a picture of my heart?
Is this the skinniest thing I've ever seen in my life,
Bro?
You got to start lifting man.
You're getting to self.
Would do it.
He hurt my friend.
What does that supposed to mean?
You're about to get yourself into a world of trouble.
My friend gives me a term.
I'll walk away.
Really lift up your glasses.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
what do you deal with?
You call me out and then
you're gonna find me.
What do you mean?
What am I doing?
Well,
if you punched me,
you guys need a number of the gym.
You guys need to start lifting.
Are you sure about that?
Let's go.
Let's do it.
I got to get on the bike to
lift.
You better.
Put it over your shoulder and walk with it.
All right,
let's go
five
oh shit.
Awesome,
Bro.
I say,
let's go,
but you start going
make some money.
What's up,
bro?
Even lift.
Do you even live,
Bro?
Are you looking at that?
Skinnylicious man,
you know the girl was bigger than you,
but I started lifting because that guy was pretty cool about it.
Yeah.
Excuse me.
Do you mean lift?
Yeah.
Do you even lift bro?
Meme comes from,
Oh,
okay,
now I get it.
I just thought it was people being silly online.
I didn't know that there was a video that it originated from.
That makes sense.
That's French bomb square space.
What do you mean?
What do you say?
Try to look like a big shot.
So what do you mean?
I tried to look like a big salary talking about I'm just walking to my car.
Yeah,
that guy's lucky.
You didn't get beat.
I know.
Why do people think that's funny?
It is kind of funny.
Do you even lift bro is a funny thing to say to people,
but man,
these guys getting close to getting fucked up on a regular basis.
That's the people like I think is that I don't get hit.
I think it's real.
I don't think he stages these beforehand and I just think it's fun to watch
people do uncomfortable things.
Yeah.
Oh that guy just rate reached out his hand.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Well this is one of the things like we're talking about with the and Anthony
thing,
like how different people handle different situations.
You know like you call differently.
People handled him.
You know,
it's kind of the guy you shook his hand that probably me.
If somebody said,
why don't you lift and be like,
whatever.
That gives a shit man.
But it's,
isn't it interesting how different people handle different situations in a
completely different thing?
And you could be different every day like you,
the way you handle one situation.
Like if that guy came up to you today or if that guy came up to you immediately
after the DMV for hours thing,
fucked up.
Anything wrong.
Fight with a girl.
Fight with a guy,
fight with a mom.
Fight with the dad,
fight with a boss.
Whatever it is.
Traffic,
bullshit.
Flat tire.
Someone stole your laptop.
Fuck you.
I don't lift fucking asshole.
You know it depends entirely on where you're at.
That is a problem with human beings.
We're not ready.
Somebody beat his ass.
This guy,
this guy.
This,
you're going to hit me if you said it again.
Oh,
whoa.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Really?
You want to get a battery charge doing a that day you will do what?
Say it again.
Say what again?
A poop my pants.
I'm sorry.
I think you guys are going smell chicken legs.
Hands
call it a chicken leg.
I'm using her reaction.
That was good.
And it's you being frank.
This is even lists break.
Uh,
easy reaction.
Your reaction was priceless,
Bro.
That's real awesome.
That's actually kind of fun.
I'm glad he does that.
At least some love.
How much I love how much shit you can do to somebody as long as afterwards like,
hey man,
this is going on youtube.
Yeah,
I'm going to be famous.
Fuck,
I'm telling you I'm gonna kick your ass.
Silly.
But you can get in trouble,
man.
People don't know they're being pranked.
They might fucking hate you and they might hate you because you seem crazy.
I'm a crazy person coming up to him starting shit for no reason.
They don't know you.
You might be nuts,
man.
And it might make it worse that your videotape him.
Look,
I'd look at all these videos that we've been showing lately.
People just freak out when they're getting videotaped.
They don't give a shit if it's a joke or not.
He gun chick that was hitting that dude.
If he's telling the truth.
By the way,
uh,
Jamie's just showed me on Gawker right now.
There's a whole story where they interviewed them,
uh,
the guy and he's completely wrote it out exactly what happened.
What happened after he thought he was still recording,
but when she hit his camera,
it turned it off and he thought he was still recording and scratched it also.
And then they said that they were going to go call pat and pat was going to take
care of all of this.
And so they went to the car and said he was like,
what the hell?
And so he sent the,
uh,
his girlfriend who was back at the house,
I guess he was gone for like an hour video and they called the police and
everything,
but they were gone and,
but uh,
yeah,
it's written all out though.
And his girlfriend.
The video.
Yeah.
Well,
just in case if they took his phone,
like that kind of shit,
he just wanted to show like,
look what happened.
Like look what's going on right now.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
strange world.
We live in when you send a video over their phone through the cellular network.
Isn't it Shitty and compressed though?
No,
not anymore.
It used to be,
mm.
I don't know about that.
I just got one the other day.
That definitely wasn't perfect.
It was an iPhone.
The iPhone.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
it should be fine.
Unless it's over I think two minutes then it might start compressing it,
but normal videos you like,
you know,
like a minute clip or whatever.
It's usually fine.
Eddie Bravo sent me a video of me getting out of that tank,
that crazy.
Um,
um,
frozen 240 degree below zero tank and it looks like shit.
I didn't know that.
If you cross platform it,
a lot of times it'll be coming.
Same Platform.
Yeah.
Here's an iPhone.
I have an iPhone and send it to me.
I saw that on your Twitter,
by the way.
What is that about?
The 240 degree a thing.
What happens is you go into this thing for two minutes and what happens is your
body thinks you just got dropped off at the top of the world.
Like there's 240 degrees below,
zero is insanely cold and he'd do it for two minutes and your body rushes all
your blood to the surface of your skin to try to heat it up because it's
freaking out.
I can't believe how cold it is.
And then when you get out after two minutes,
it realize like,
oh,
this is like normal temperature and everything relaxes.
And the idea that flushes out inflammation,
it's incredibly efficient at like if you have injuries and inflammation,
incredibly efficient at reducing it.
Did it help you to fuck?
Yeah.
That's great.
It makes you feel good too.
It's really crazy.
Is it painful while you're actually in the negative to 40 no,
no,
no.
Just weird to colts even care.
It's quick.
You know,
because it's so quick,
Brian,
I'm a send it to you.
See if you could throw it up or should I send to you Jamie,
which ones on this an expensive thing or is this something that could be in
malls and a couple of years?
Oh,
it's expensive as fuck.
Um,
it's expensive to have one of those.
That's um,
that's what,
it's expensive.
But to use it,
I'm not sure.
I don't think it's that much.
I don't remember quite honest with you.
It sounds like a cool idea and it sounds like it's kind of polar opposite of why
people go to Saunas,
get all the,
you know,
well,
expand your,
um,
if scan and whatnot and get toxins out just in some ways.
In some ways it's kind of the opposite,
but in other ways it's just another way to get your body to do things that are,
you know,
better than just resting.
You know,
the Sonor picks up your growth hormone.
It picks up like,
um,
Doctor Rhonda Patrick wrote a whole piece on the benefits of the sauna.
Apparently Sauna has like some,
like that hyper heating environment and like the hot air for short periods of
time has a pretty significant effects on a recovery in the body.
So the Russians had it right all along,
man.
Ever seen that thing they do called the Banya?
Yeah,
they had it right all along.
They would do a,
these hot cold bass.
It would go back and forth.
They want to do this Banya thing where they,
uh,
they go to the sauna and they slap sticks on it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I saw,
I saw a vice video about that.
It's pretty fucking cool.
Yeah.
Um,
I'll email to you Brian,
should I email to you Jamie?
Oh,
you meant to Brian.
Brian.
Okay.
Um,
okay.
What is it Brian?
Hold on.
You know what it is?
Yeah.
I'm just trying to find in here.
All right,
so on sweaty,
um,
what were we talking about?
Cool.
Shit.
But who'll shit happening?
No,
what was,
but what was it,
what was the subject that we're just talking about before the,
uh,
before the video?
Yeah,
before this thing.
I'm sending it to him.
Um,
before that I was just going on my ramble about how bitcoin is going to change
everything.
No,
I had to,
I had a point about this fucking tank thing and I forgot it now.
Oh,
I was asking about the price and you were saying,
I'm not sure.
The place that I went to was in Hollywood,
you know,
I don't know how much it cost.
I should look it up.
I should look it up cause it's a good spot.
But athletes are using a Coby Brian.
I was like one of the first guys to bring it back from Europe.
It's just a,
in Europe they've figured out a quicker than America and America's onto it.
Now that inflammation is one of the huge causes of all sorts of ailments in the
body.
Physical injuries and sicknesses,
inflammation from your diet,
inflammation from a exercise,
strange stress,
all sorts of different things that cause your body to have inflammation.
Then it fucks up a lot of systems of the body and for recovery,
reducing inflammation,
it's really critical.
They used to do these ice baths or guys would uh,
go into uh,
like a tub,
like this big steel tub and they would just pour buckets of ice in there and
cold water and you would sit submerged inside this thing and it would do the,
a similar version of it,
but it takes far longer.
It wasn't nearly as effective.
Then they figured out how to do this one,
which is really,
um,
I mean it's just really not that painful.
It's interesting.
It's weird.
You,
you,
you do it and you get of there like,
Whoa,
Ooh,
you know,
like your whole body.
It's like,
it just feels like as soon as you warm up everything just like it's his,
cause it's only two minutes,
everything just free flows and it feels like you have like extra blood pumping
through your body or something.
You feel like you just get this charge of energy.
That sounds cool.
It's really cool.
I'm gonna,
I'm going to look into that just out of curiosity because I do infrared Saunas
and I get,
uh,
you feel good for the rest of that whole day.
If you do the sauna like three or 4:00 PM,
the rest of the day you're a little bit lighter,
a little bit friendlier and like everything is nicer.
Yeah.
Massage is great for that too.
There's all sort of cryo healthcare.
That's the name of the place.
Um,
how much does it cost?
Is it,
say it has a store,
let's find out how much it costs.
But it's something that,
uh,
they figured out like a lot of different things they figured out in Europe.
There it is.
That's me coming out of it.
Right?
Yeah.
That shouldn't be that compressed.
That's not even a long,
yeah.
Video.
That would only two minutes to you.
I could have done another minute.
How did it get on with it?
It's cool.
I liked the breathing.
Like you breed you like you can do that.
Pulled them out.
I mean,
the breathing was really weird.
Perfect.
Okay.
Very good.
It was awesome.
Wow.
That was incredible.
It's crazy how hard it is to breathe in there.
That's the weird thing.
When you breathe it up.
Ooh.
It's like a labored breath,
you know?
That's it.
That's the video.
But a,
I'm going to do it all the time now.
I can't wait to do it again.
Hmm.
They have them all over the place.
Uh,
Ian Mccall does it every day.
He's the,
one of the fighters for the UFC flyweight division,
one of the best in the world.
He does it every day.
He's doing that.
Cryotherapy shit goes in.
He went up to 263 degrees below zero,
because he's an extremist.
He does like three minutes and 20 seconds,
something fucking ridiculous.
Longest anyone's ever done.
The coldest everyone anyone's ever done.
That's kind of Shitty,
negative,
any negative.
No,
not to me.
You know,
I don't know what happens with other folks.
You turn it into sub zero,
you start freezing and other people,
they start you off slow though.
Um,
there's many,
many articles on cryotherapy though.
Uh,
both cryotherapy applied to sports and athletic performance.
Cryotherapy applied to a injury and recovery.
There's a bunch of different things you could do.
Now.
It's interesting.
There's a thing called the hyperbaric chamber.
There's that,
that,
uh,
aids and recovery and uh,
oxygen utilization,
healing of the body.
Like guys who have injuries like you're right a favor.
He had,
um,
a bunch of,
uh,
contusions on his leg from his fight.
He got leg kicked a lot.
Like it was fucked up and swollen and he went into a hyperbaric chamber.
That helps.
Yeah,
it helps him with his hands to his guys.
He's getting his hands healed after he broke and we went to the hyperbaric
chamber.
It's pretty incredible.
Cool.
Yeah,
they have some amazing shit now.
We're just,
we're just a few years
away from creating like bulletproof,
immortal,
mortal people,
you know?
I mean we're,
we're maybe like a hundred,
like if,
if we live to be a hundred years more,
if human beings don't blow each other up,
they're going to have bulletproof skin.
They're going to have Oregon's that never tire.
They're going to have a genetic code that just never drops off.
I think we're less than a hundred years away from the actual FTL drive if it,
if it can be built,
I think it will be built in the next hundred years.
FTL Yeah,
faster than light.
Really.
NASA,
NASA came out with that.
It was just a media stunt,
you know,
it was like a computer generated image of what an FTL star ship might look like.
I saw that.
Yeah.
The warp drive,
the warp drive thing,
and I think if it's going to happen again,
like assuming we don't,
I'll kill each other.
It'll happen in the next hundred years because the technology is at the point
where we could get there eventually.
How would you say that [inaudible] could give you any indication that they will
be able to surpass the speed of light?
It seems like an energy problem and I don't even know what kind of advances are
going to happen in energy just within our lifetime.
So it,
hmm.
I don't want to pretend them the FTL drive expert,
but that scientist he's working on it came up with some kind of innovation where
it would require far less energy than they originally thought to do this,
uh,
you know,
warp of the space,
time fabric or whatever the fuck it does.
And the fact that he figured that out means that now they can work on a proof of
concept.
They can do a very small version and a laboratory one day and once they have
that,
that's all you need to get industry interested,
you know,
like why,
why should we build a faster than light spacecraft?
It's kind of a self explanatory thing.
Like the coolest shit.
You can get resources anywhere in the galaxy,
of course people are going to try to build it if it becomes reasonable.
It's interesting if you look back on 1940 what was it,
45 when the atomic bomb was first detonated and think about 1945 to today and
then how,
how long it has a 70 plus years.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean think about how primitive our technology was back then.
They had the stupid radios,
the tube radios that would get like two channels and they built a nuclear bomb.
No kidding.
Right.
And now we have smartphones that are so good.
I mean I was thinking about how uh,
the year 2000 I had a palm pilot and it was really like psyched about it cause
it was the best you could have pop poppop antenna.
The little I had the heart antenna,
the nub.
I have the one that it would come up like you,
you would pull up and went to school.
If you are very lucky and all the stars were aligned,
you could send an email,
the shitty little keyboard.
Can you pay like $70 a month for the data plan for like 500 kilobytes or
something?
Yeah.
I enjoyed my palm pilot.
I felt like I had a computer with me.
I was being fucking real.
I was on,
I was on the ball,
I was on the technology ball.
But compare that to today and that's only 14 years.
Amazing.
You know what amazes me the most still to this day Shizam that app that you can
like you hear a song and you just press that and do it.
Dude,
I did it the other day.
It was loud as fuck in this restaurant and this song was playing and I was like,
that song,
it's cool.
What the fuck is that song?
And I was like,
this isn't gonna work perfect instantly.
I mean the APP gets better
all the time too.
Yeah.
That APP.
Like like whatever they've done to it.
Maybe it's the new processing power of the new phones.
Cause as a phone's getting more powerful and more resources are available for
these apps to figure things out like that.
I don't know how it does it.
I don't understand how it works,
but it's incredible what we can do now.
Incredible.
The heart rate monitors that work off of the flash on the back of the phone.
Yeah.
That's insane.
It's pretty cool.
Put your finger over the camera.
I even use the,
um,
the 10,000 steps thing that the Samsung has where it tells you when you've hit
10,000 steps in a day.
Really?
I try to hit that because it's just good.
Like if I look down and it's 8:00 PM,
and it says only 6,000 steps,
I'm like,
oh,
I'll just go walk to the,
uh,
the La River is kind of close to where I live.
It's like I'll just walk down there and back because they know it's about 4,000
steps.
I do that and then I feel like I've hit my quota for the day.
So you have a cell phone that's keeping me healthy pretty much.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
I'm a maniac dog.
Get those 10,000 out before I did anything,
just so I can be able to do whatever the fuck I want for the rest of the day.
I would just find a staircase and keep walking up and down and like an idiot.
I probably would.
I'm not kidding.
I can't have something like that where there's a number in front of me that I
have to achieve every day because I'll,
I'll just go nuts.
I'll just do it right away.
Just hated immediately.
Yeah,
I'll just go.
Okay.
What time is it?
It's a nine o'clock by 10 o'clock I'm going to have 10,000 steps ready co by
the,
how long would it take you to do 10,000 steps?
It's not that long.
It's like a maybe like 20 or 30 minutes of walking.
It's done.
That's it.
I think so.
That's all you needed to do in a day.
I mean it's got to be brisk walking,
but he considered brisk,
like just short of a power walk.
Pretty much like I'm not jogging,
but I'm,
when I walk it's to get cardio,
so
that's interesting.
Do you ever do that?
Sometimes at the airport,
sometimes the airport,
when I know I have like a long walk,
I treat it like a workout and I just say I'm just going to walk 50% faster than
I would ever walk and just give it that extra like,
and when I hit the ground like push off that motherfucker push,
push,
push.
I don't do that at airports because I just,
I kinda shut down in airports.
I feel like you're almost like this,
this freight that just needs to be transported to where you need to go.
Like I'm normally in my head and before you know it,
you're
there.
I um,
like music,
man,
I'm very rarely at the airport without music.
Very rarely makes the whole trip so much more fun when you're sitting down and
just chilling out,
waiting for your flight to take off and you have some really good music.
Like you don't even mind.
You might waiting if you can enjoy the music.
The problem with a lot of travel is the downtime problem.
That's the problem.
The problem is you're not doing what you want to do,
but what people don't think of is that you can do what you want to do while
you're doing what you don't want to do.
Like if there's a time where you have to do something,
like just sit and wait.
You can listen to a book on tape,
you can go to audible.com get the book on tape,
you can listen to this podcast,
you can listen to some cool music and it makes it better.
It,
it literally makes,
it's better than just sitting there like a dummy.
Like when is this thing going to take off?
You just plunk plunk crank.
I did the this weekend for Vegas.
I was listening to the shooter Jennings ever everlasting shooter Jennings.
Holy Shit.
Well,
and Jenny's son as some fucking talent.
He's a good dude.
He's got some great songs.
It's really good.
Interesting stuff too.
So that was my,
that was my,
uh,
travel time.
I travel time was listening to some new music.
It's always good books.
I like reading on flights because nobody can interrupt you.
There's no like a phone call or nonsense.
I like riding on flights.
That's my,
I get some of my best writing done on flights for whatever reason.
Hmm.
Are you working on a book or something?
Cause I think you've mentioned before that you've right.
Yeah,
well I write shit down and I'll eventually probably put together as a book,
but I'm not giving myself any,
I like,
especially right now I'm concentrating almost entirely on writing stand up.
I'm going to do my next special and the tick is actually just went on sale today
for a Denver.
I'm going to be in Denver on,
um,
August 22nd and 23rd,
22nd.
It's Friday night.
It's like the night before the taping just to have fun and do some shows and get
loose.
And then on Saturday night I'm recording my comedy show at the comedy works and
it should be fun.
Denver's a cool city.
I like Colorado in general.
Colorado's the shit and right now it's changing trainging radically.
It's like all this marijuana money is really what it's transferring the
consciousness of this,
uh,
entire city.
A lot of people concerned about it,
you know,
they're worried about,
nefarious elements getting involved and all sorts of Weirdos and biker gangs and
who knows who's going to have money now and what the pros to me so severely
outweigh the cons.
It's like you're giving adults the ability to choose responsibly.
Whether they use it or don't use it,
you're,
what you're doing is you're giving people freedom and freedom always makes
better.
People just does.
So long as no one's getting hurt,
you're not going to have freedom to fucking sell poison.
You're not talking about freedom to shoot darts at fucking babies.
What you're talking about is freedom to ingest a plant that grows naturally on
earth.
Yeah.
And the government lets you frack for thousands of miles,
but you can't,
you can't blow a puff of smoke in the air that happens to be an herb they don't
like.
It's one of those things where it's so intrinsically ridiculous that that's why
it's changing all at once.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
We have the,
I think this is one of the coolest times ever to be alive.
I really do.
And I think that one of the reasons why it's one of the coolest times ever to be
alive is because it's just so chaotic and it's so strange and no one can do
anything about it.
No one can stop it.
Now they're going to try to net neutrality and they're going to try to put the
brakes here and charge people for that.
And you're going to,
you're in trouble and you're on a list and I'm going to watch you.
What are you trying to be anonymous?
You've fucker.
I want to know where you were.
We were,
we were talking about this right before the show.
Like all that shit that's coming out,
like all the corruption and anger and government and competence.
I'm starting to believe that it has to be there because that's wakes us up to,
we don't need so many agencies.
We don't need like so many wars and so much bullshit.
Let's just decide things for ourselves.
And of course we need some laws.
We need some police,
we need some roads.
And that's really it.
Thank you very much.
You know,
like have a nice day.
We don't need you archiving fucking baby photos.
That's what you've gone over the line.
And so you're seeing the people realize that people realize that banks are
ineffective ingredient.
People realize that the old media is dying out and they don't give a shit about
their viewers.
So they're just moving over to better stuff and it's happening across the board
and pretty much every industry even.
Um,
I had,
uh,
this woman Tiffany van [inaudible] on my show recently,
he was another podcast host and she was talking to me about how all these
grocery stores now have an organic section and that's taking off.
And so you're seeing like this,
we have new standards.
Like that's,
I think what's happening is that we have higher standards than we used to.
And so across the board is better stuff.
Yeah.
There's no doubt that things are getting more complex and harder to control.
There was no doubt.
And there's no doubt that these old systems,
whether it's like afternoon,
when you watch the news at six or five or whatever the fuck it is,
it seems like you're watching a parody,
right?
The anchorman is becoming more and more.
I mean when you watch,
if you try to watch like the La News,
try to watch any of those channels.
Local news at five o'clock it's like these people were aliens,
right?
I need these.
I think these things,
we're not supposed to exist forever and that's why to us it seems so kind of
silly.
It's like it's supposed to be dying out.
That's like the,
it's the new season.
New stuff's going to come out.
It's kind of like fashion,
right?
Like every year it's going to be something different.
That's the way it works.
Now it's a corporate media and centralization,
top down type stuff is dying out and I'm sure it'll continue to exist in a bunch
of different forms,
but that idea is getting weaker and weaker.
I think that eventually afternoon news,
Evening News,
whatever it is,
is going to be like a burlesque show.
Like people are going to pull it out on stage like she's an astrologer thing
like riding a unicycle or fucking being in a covered wagon.
Like take my photo,
I'm in a covered wagon.
We're going to go watch the local news.
It's a new show where they just,
they leave out like really important parts of historic events because they don't
jive with the government plan.
I mean,
that would be really funny.
Like watching like a news report,
you could easily do a parody of a news report of the fervor after 2011 or 2001
rather after September 11th you could easily do some sort of a government
propaganda.
Fox News at its worst,
but just oh,
so subtle show and people would,
you know,
people would eat it up and 10 years from now it probably will be like burlesque.
It really,
you would watch a burlesque show.
Isn't that kind of like cold bear does in terms of he takes that model,
makes it a little bit ridiculous.
Yup.
And now he does have millions of viewers,
so I mean it's going to take over Letterman spot.
Yeah.
Just hilarious.
When does that start?
Well,
what's weird is what is he going to do?
Is he going to be cold bear?
Hmm.
No,
I heard he's not.
That's what it's going to be himself.
Yeah.
You know,
he's like an ardent Catholic.
Is He really?
Yeah.
He's like the guy is a serious Catholic.
Interesting.
Yeah,
that is interesting.
I didn't know that.
I maybe would just be a new character unless that's a character too.
Maybe that's character too.
Maybe the Catholic things bullshit.
He's just playing that character as well.
Yeah.
Who knows?
What do you think?
I Dunno.
I think he's probably going to play a version of himself mixed with like a late
night talk show host character.
You know,
it's probably,
you know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
like hey,
welcome back guys.
You know,
but he's still going to be himself but not be quick.
Yeah.
It's a very quick guy.
Very,
very,
uh,
cause Leno was a character that wasn't really,
I know,
you know.
Yeah.
But he doesn't think that,
I don't know.
He's so much better with just cars.
I watched Jay Leno's car shows,
like he's got this Jay Leno's garage with Jay's garage.
It's fucking great.
And I'm watching.
I was like,
this could be a really good show.
Like why didn't you do this all the whole time?
Because you see him on the tonight show it.
It's just so,
you know it's forced.
He's talking if I like,
that's that bit that Bill Hicks she used to do about them talking to Joey
Lawrence,
pulling out a gun and blowing his brains out and it,
and it forms an NBC peacock on the wall because he's a company man until the
bitter end.
It was a great classic bit,
but in a way,
I mean the reason why the bit was funny it was,
cause it kind of was true.
Like what was he doing?
He used to be a great comic and now he's a shill.
This like guy who's just selling people's TV shows he doesn't give a fuck about
and but you know what?
He gives a fuck about cars.
I've seen him on I think discovery channel before and he's lit up like a
Christmas tree.
Just super excited.
He will,
he knows everything about cars and not just everything about cars of today.
He knows about steam powered cars and old cars and electric cars.
I mean he's got like a,
a fleet of automobiles.
He works on them.
He's got this Jay Leno's,
Jay Jay's garage show,
and he loves them like this.
He's doing Jay Leno has more money than he will ever know what to do with.
He's rich as fuck,
and he had so much money that he made from stand up that he never touched any of
us tonight.
Show money.
He was like proud of that,
that you just put it all in the bank.
So all those cars,
whatever's house costs,
all that shit that's always stand up.
Comedy money.
Wow.
Yeah.
You guys get a fuck load of money.
He is not spending the money he makes from the TV show.
Nope.
He doesn't have to.
It makes a lot of money doing stand up.
It's got to be an insane amount of money by now.
It must be insane.
You just put it all in the bank.
But the point being like he doesn't need money,
but he's doing it because he loves cars.
That's what everybody should do and that nobody would ever have had these issues
with Jay Leno if he did that.
You know,
you remember when Jimmy Kimmel went on a show and mocked him cause he was trying
to take Conan's job back and no one would have ever done that if it was just his
car show.
You know,
there's no competition,
there's no,
he's just having a great time talking about cars.
It's cool to see.
It's cool to see somebody like kind of get that and it's like the Internet has
transformed a lot of people's ideas of who Jay Leno is.
That's really
cool.
It's cool when you can see the other side of somebody where you only see the
little public piece that pushed out there.
Well he's,
you know,
that job's weird job man.
Being the host
I chats and other anachronism,
it's for sure going to fade out is if you look at the demographics,
that idea of like Letterman and Leno,
I don't see that existing even 15 years.
Like I would put the,
the lifespan of that concept it 15 years at the absolute most because of the
people watching it.
Now,
how old are they?
50 or 60 how old are they in 10 or 15 years?
Chelsea handler and she's kind of doing that and she's going to do that on
Netflix now.
Well that seems to me like an Internet show.
That format seems different where you have not true or it's like a panel like
panels.
I don't have as much of an issue with the panel is that seems very like the way
you should do a show almost that the,
the late night thing,
I just don't see it existing because not only are people getting older,
a lot of old people are liking podcasts now.
Like I've got some older listeners and I'm sure you do because it's not that
hard.
Like we make it seem like it's this huge Chaz.
It's really not like you get bored of what's on TV at night.
You flip around through iTunes on your phone.
Now you're a podcast listener.
You've just switched demographics,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
I know what you're saying.
It's the problem with something like podcasting as opposed to these other things
is that you know,
if you have a show on NBC,
you can't not be a shale.
There's no way you're going to be that.
The talk show host for the tonight show,
you're going to be on CBS are going to be your,
I mean,
you can have a certain amount of room for creative expression,
but essentially what you're trying to do is you're trying to be entertaining
while you're promoting people's projects and that's how you get access to Tom
Cruise.
It's what it is,
you know?
And if you're,
you're some wild fucker,
you're not going to get access to Tom Cruise.
He knows that you kind of have to be Barack Obama.
How many times does he interviewed Barack Obama's?
Yup.
Fuck ain't did,
that's a good point.
Where,
you know,
he's a hundred percent safe.
I was on with Ron Paul.
Yeah,
last time I did the tonight show.
Jay's a fucking really nice guy though.
He's a very nice guy and I really liked him on his car show.
It's really cool to say,
you know,
I don't know what kind of crazy shit he did.
You know,
when he was trying to get that letter when Letterman and him were duking it out
and they made those,
uh,
those,
that TV show about,
remember that made for TV movie the late shift.
Yeah.
It was like at Hbo movie that they made on the struggle.
Who knows how much of that was true and how much of it was and I don't know,
but apparently Jaylen,
oh really did hide in the closet while this guy was having conversations about
him and then use that information against him.
I just kind of funny
like I think Leno has a bit of a spine though.
Cause I've seen him do some skits on surveillance type stuff and criticized
various policies.
Like he's not a complete uh,
uh,
like company man.
Right.
Like he,
he does use that from time to time.
He had you and Ron Paul on.
We didn't talk about,
I mean I especially didn't talk about too much crazy.
I just said that,
but just what I'm saying is just by doing that he's being kind of better than he
could be.
Yeah.
He had me on though because NBC had fear factor on.
Oh I don't think it was his like,
I mean I'm sure he could probably veto me.
He's always been nice to me.
But I said that wasn't a decision where like,
cause he's a comedian.
You're a comedian.
I don't think so.
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean I would assume Jay Leno has a lot of power over who he chooses or knots
chooses to talk to or not talk to on a show.
It's not like they needed me on.
It could have been the envy if you said like,
no way that guy's a dick.
But you know,
I'm sure he could get black balled it.
But at Ron Paul for sure is a controversial character.
But when I was talking about so much stuff,
that's what's so funny is a few years ago people like Ron Paul would've fucking
crazy federal reserve.
And then so much I started looking into it.
A lot of people did.
It's like,
well the Federal Reserve is actually pretty crazy.
So he was right about that is right about the whole like,
we shouldn't be going into all these places.
Cause now you see Iraq,
like what the fuck did we spend all this time and money over there for if
they're now falling back into the same chaos.
Yeah.
Do,
what is Isis?
I have no idea.
I honestly have not heard of them up until about two weeks ago.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah,
you're on the ball.
Yeah.
Like that's the first I'd heard about them.
You're on the ball.
I mean you're on top of it.
If I,
if there's anything weird shit in the news,
you,
one of my favorite people to talk to because you usually have,
if it was anything really significant,
usually have a pretty detailed idea of what's going on.
You don't even know what Isis is.
Yeah.
I talked to some people the other night that gave me a fairly good explanation.
Brian Cowan is on top of it.
Of course.
Uh,
the Sunni's in the she eyes.
Apparently it has a lot to do with that,
but it's,
um,
it's a really bad militant jihadist organization and scaring the fuck out of
people.
And uh,
it sounds like like a team of bad guys in the Avengers.
It doesn't,
it,
it does sound a little,
uh,
that totally sounds avenger like isis.
It's that,
it's like,
okay,
this is more evidence that life's not real.
I'm in a movie.
We're definitely end up bad guys,
but definitely in a movie or at least the video game or something.
You think so.
I think life is too weird.
Like for me on a personal level is just too bizarre.
Too many checks getting some bitches.
Things are just happening so quick.
I don't mean like my own life and things are happening so quickly in such a cool
way.
Like the whole currency thing I consider to be psychedelic,
the whole legalization thing is literally psychedelic and then just this
internet thing and how people seem to know what's going on in 20 years ago,
they really didn't like,
there's something very cool about that and the progress rate,
it almost doesn't feel like reality.
It feels like it's a simulation we're all in and I'm not saying it actually
gives because who the fuck knows.
It just seems like a lot of really interesting,
weird things happen that by pure probability,
why would this even happen?
It seems like it's kind of an adventure.
I agree that it is an adventure,
but I think it really is an adventure.
I don't know if there's no plan,
there's no design and yeah,
I'm not convinced that it's a simulation,
but I wouldn't be shocked if it was,
I mean,
I probably would be shocked,
but logically speaking,
if I looked at all the possibles and the variables,
I would say that it being a simulation,
it's definitely in the mix,
but even if it's not a simulation,
it's a simulation because you are born and now you have this localized
consciousness.
You
don't know why.
You don't know what you're supposed to do.
Like crazy.
People claim that,
you know,
God speaks to them for the rest of us,
we don't know what the fuck to do.
Right.
We're here for 70 or 80 or 90 years.
Then that the game ends.
What was the purpose?
What were the rules?
You don't know,
but it does feel a little bit like a video game.
There's a certain life cycle to the game.
Certain little obstacles and people talk about synchronicity,
which is a,
it borders on being like secret type stuff,
but I think there's something to it.
I mean the secret like action.
There's a difference between law of attraction,
like nonsense and synchronicity,
which I believe is a re I don't understand it.
I just believe it's real.
What do you think it is?
And Carl
synchronicity,
you mean thinking about things and they come true.
Having friends think about them and they call you coincidental events that take
place.
Like what specifically do you think of when you think of synchronicity?
Yeah,
it's those moments where like you're on a flight and at the last minute your,
your seat changes and the person you sit next to is the agent who signs you and
then your career takes off.
And I talked to people where that happens all the time and it seems like if life
were just this mouthy ASEAN fucking thing that we all go,
go,
go through and grind through and there's no purpose whatsoever and no design at
all and nothing to it aside from like just maybe reproduce and then die.
If that were the case,
I don't think all this cool stuff would be happening.
There's constant synergy.
Things are getting so much better so quickly that it seems almost like this is
where we're supposed to be and it's leading towards something
that's fascinating.
I wonder,
um,
I look at the whole,
if you look at the big picture of the whole universe,
everything starting from the big bang,
spreading out planets,
forming stars,
giving,
you know,
solar,
these solar nebulas um,
solar nurseries giving birth to stars and you,
you think about what does this whole process and what's it trying to do?
It's constantly trying to make more complex shit.
Like everything is more complex.
A planet cools off.
Biological life begins to form.
Life starts shooting rockets out.
It starts like streaming things down for spinning things in the air above the
planet in orbit,
you know,
blowing nuclear bombs up in the atmosphere.
And if you look at that and it's trying to get off,
it's trying to figure out a way to complicate itself.
Trying to figure out a way to get more biologically,
um,
more,
more biologically advanced to the point where it's not going to die.
It's trying to figure out how to kill diseases and spread information fast and
the speed of light is trying to figure out how to travel in space through warp
drives.
I mean think about all the things it's trying to do.
It's trying to populate other planets,
in which case it'll continue to evolve as technology continue to get smarter,
continued to change,
its cool its capacity to change the world,
the environments open up wormholes,
start traveling to other dimensions.
I mean it's going to populate the whole earth.
It's going to populate the whole galaxy.
It's going to populate the whole universe.
It's going to keep going.
It's a crazy little weird thing and it's consciousness
and we're bodies that carry consciousness around the same way a jug carries
water around and we are consciousness figures out a way to evolve the body and
the environment and changes things and move things around and improves things.
And right now it's improving.
The very society that we live in,
the very culture that we operate on is changing radically because of technology,
technology and human innovation,
human creativity changing the actual earth itself,
building,
we'll just pop up 30 40 stories should build them out of the ground,
figure out how to engineer and planes and bridges.
You could drive across passable lakes and all this shit is being done like
right.
Like that being being bang,
Bang,
Bang.
It's just happening.
It's highly.
What's cool is we've layered in capitalism,
so we're doing all these things that are essentially just creative and are not
at all necessary to get laid or to get food.
You know,
like that's what it comes down to for most species and instead were talking and
building stuff and doing all the things that human beings do.
We don't need to be doing any of it.
It's amazing.
It makes you believe,
almost like we're,
these creativity engines are kind of chaos engines that are just churning out
ideas because for sure you don't need to be as smart as we are to survive on
this planet.
But you do if you want to survive,
you know,
for a long fucking time.
Yeah.
But,
but what I wanted to add that,
but I kind of forgot to add in there as the capitalism thing.
What I was saying is that,
uh,
we've transferred it so that all these things that are essentially just art and
creativity are now survival for us.
Cause we can make money from that.
So if you're a rocket ship designer 300 years ago,
that doesn't mean anything.
If you're,
if you're a great sculptor,
300 years ago,
you're still probably in the fields.
Like you got to eat food,
right?
You gotta do it now.
It takes no time at all for that shit.
So you can actually be a sculpture.
You can go to Nyu or Columbia or something and learn how to be a fucking
sculptor.
And you can become a rocket designer and do that and you'll actually be
compensated.
So you're doing these things that are completely not essential to your own
existence,
but it's been kind of transferred into this thing where you're like,
I have to do this so I can survive.
So it's very cool if you think about it.
Yeah,
it's not essential,
but it's something that's desirable and it's something that helps make our life
more interesting.
So you're willing to give up some bitcoin for it.
And next thing I know it's junk,
junk,
junk.
You're off to the races.
Yeah.
We were,
you know,
I think we live in,
in the most exciting time ever.
I think this is the best time ever to be alive as a human.
I think if you look back on all the different,
I mean everybody wants to cry that the sky is falling and you know,
pollution and warming has changed.
Like that's what what people have to be aware of is,
uh,
you know,
I was saying different things in 2011 because it was a different world in 2011.
And I'll be saying different things in 2017 cause there'll be a different world.
And if you're always saying the same thing,
like there are financial experts who've been saying that the collapse is coming
for the past 25 years.
Literally like just put your money into gold now it's coming folks.
And it never came.
100% never happened.
The recession.
Uh,
one of the few good things Obama has done seems to have us,
seems to have gotten us out of the recession through a combination of things.
And that collapsed that they'd try to sell you on newsletters and stuff is not
happening.
It's not going to happen in the way that it's described.
It's not even going to feel like a collapse.
Like when you consider the Internet to be the collapse of civilization.
No.
It's just like the growth of civilization.
It's a collapse of Jesus.
It's the collapse of easy corporate money is what it is.
The collapse of a lot of things wrong.
A lot of stupid shit is getting flushed out.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's always going to be that way.
So he's going to be,
there's going to be an old method and the old method is replaced by a better
method.
The old methods trial struggles to try to stay relevant and it never makes it.
And this is no one's riding wagons around man.
There's no wagon trains.
There's this great quote that made the rounds a western union and like the 1870s
or something,
you probably saw this like this telephone has no use whatsoever.
It was,
it was about the telephone and that was pretty much what it said.
Like this telephone is too novel to ever gain mainstream acceptance.
We were talking about the war worlds the other day and the Orson wells thing,
the radio show and about how they were talking about radio being a new medium
and that radio is a new thing and then we have to figure out how to control.
It's the broadcasts and that must've felt like telepathy for them for the first
five or 10 years because now you have FDR or whoever,
like in your living room talking to Ya.
It must have been cool as shit.
Yeah.
You know,
and also they were all probably drunk at the time,
drunk and high.
So they were like,
Holy Shit.
Fdrs in the other room.
And plus it's got to really stimulate the imagination.
Just think he's talking,
he didn't even get to see him except in the movie theaters.
Did he go to the movie theaters and they'd play them like these clips ever seen
those clips that I've seen some of the war clips to.
Amazing.
Like they would play like clips of soldiers over there doing battle.
But other than that you had to pretend that you could imagine like you got to
look at the newspaper stories and you'd get like a black and white photo and try
to piece together what it was like to be there.
I saw this great thing online that uh,
um,
it was talking about how we assume that we're all rude now cause we're all
looking down at our phones the whole time.
Well it showed a photo of a subway in New York like some time in the forties and
it's all newspapers so people were just as rude back then.
We're interested in finding information.
They were just doing a kind of crude way.
Yeah,
they've always done that.
People have always sat down on like airplanes that had magazines and read
magazines and books.
They didn't just have parties and starts saying share their souls while they're
on the flight.
I was on a flight once where a lady try to proselytize.
I was on a fright flight once with my friend who's a Jewish guy,
uh,
and he got really angry.
He got really angry.
This big black woman came by and she said something to the tone,
something along the lines of,
uh,
Jesus loves you.
Uh,
I need to get Jesus to you to
put Jesus in your soul.
And she would like sing.
She was like singing while the plane was going on before she got up to tell him
about Jesus.
There was like singing by biblical songs and my friend was like,
I'm not interested.
Thank you,
not interested.
Please stop talking to me.
Can someone please have her sit down?
And The lady came over and told us she had to sit down and stop saying it.
And then,
you know,
a couple people came over and had a conversation with her.
They told him,
stop thinking about Jesus Shit.
Well,
I mean the people who have a secular upbringing,
you have a stranger coming up to,
this happens to all of us all the time.
Like there are a couple of Mormon guys,
they didn't come up to me,
but they are on their bicycles where I was a few days ago and you could see them
doing their thing and it's a combination of you feel bad for them because you
know,
they were just brought up in it.
But also like as a secular person,
I just go,
you know,
this stuff is not factually accurate.
Pushing it on people who have not asked for it,
it's unsolicited and who the fuck are you?
You're the expert on what God wants your some broke Mormon kid on a bicycle and
you're supposed to tell me what Jesus wants me to do with my life.
Like you don't even know what you're doing with your life.
Yes.
Silly,
silly people.
You can't do that.
I don't even answer the door.
Ever since I got one of those big metal doors that you can see through,
like you have one of those that decided to have that.
Let's save so much uncomfortable and like you just open up the front first door.
You could see through what's going on.
Go.
I'm not interested at slam the door.
I want to make sure you have what I'm thinking of.
You have like a nightclub slit,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I have a wooden door that's then on top of it.
It's just this huge metal door that has like pins,
holes throughout the whole thing.
She can see through it,
but barely,
but you can see what's on the other side of that door and you could talk,
but you don't have to open the door.
Glorious,
glorious times.
My friends text away,
son.
Yeah.
I,
I'm just absolutely completely fascinated by all these new things that are
coming out.
I got a new pen that I need to implement next podcast.
I'm going to do it.
I haven't set it up yet,
but you might be interested in this too for notes.
Um,
this new pen is a digital pen that takes a photograph of any note that
you don't have it and have it here.
No,
I don't have it here.
It's at home.
It's,
it's complicated.
It's one of those things I have to look at and figuring out how I'm going to,
um,
and it has the special dope books that go with it.
You write down on this notebook all your different notes.
That camera on the pen takes a photograph of the note.
Then when you go to the note,
you go to the note,
you put your pen on the note and the audio recorder will play what you were
talking about when you wrote that note.
Oh Wow.
So you could be in the middle of an interview,
be in the middle of a conversation when you're on a podcast.
Like if there's,
a lot of times I have ideas,
like there was a,
I was talking to this guy,
a Gad Saad,
uh,
the guy you met who's on the first podcast in the middle of that,
I remembered this bit that I just stopped doing.
I just stopped doing it.
But it was a great bit like,
Oh my God,
I don't,
I've never put that on anything.
So I started writing down like to have that ability to go back to that moment
and know you were thinking about when you wrote that down,
like you can,
you know,
you could save a lot of missed ideas that just sort of disappear out into the
ether when you're having these long three hour conversations.
I mean that's just another new application of technology.
That's incredibly fascinating.
That's really cool.
Think about how many ideas we've all probably had.
That would be like a life changing,
but then you forget it because the phone rings or something and never comes
back.
Yeah.
Let me pull up what,
whatever the fuck that Penn has called and this we're out of time.
We turned into a pumpkin probably.
We do a lot of,
to a lot of podcasts here.
Let me see this.
Uh,
I said,
I think I saw him.
They did.
Do you know where you got it?
Cause I think I saw them at staples the other day.
No,
I got it.
I definitely got it online.
I got it on amazon.com I don't fuck around.
So I do everything online now.
I very rarely go to a store and Bosch Shit,
I just love the idea.
It's just so weird to me that you can do that.
You could just fucking click on something and then all of a sudden it arrives at
your house and it's going to be three,
three d printers pretty soon from everything.
Everything people have been saying that's going to be really cool.
Live scribe is what it's called.
Live scribe,
eight gigabytes.
Cut Eight gigabytes of storage.
Incredible.
It works with Wifi.
Syncs up to your computer.
It's too much.
We,
we live in the strangest times ever.
This is so weird.
Like every day there's some new thing that comes at,
this is from an article I got,
but this guy was talking about,
um,
uh,
shorthand.
You ever see guys writing that Gregg shorthand?
That's what it's called.
Fascinating.
It's like they have this weird little shorthand language.
You can write like 290 words a minute.
If you're really good at it,
you can whip through it.
So when someone's talking to you,
you could literally get everything they say and then you can go back to it and
realize by reading your chicken scratch and you ever seen it.
Yeah.
Reporters do it all the time.
It's weird stuff,
man.
Not a lot of reporters anymore,
The old school,
the old school,
most of the people now they record things and then they write them down.
Then they fuck up everything you said because the Co,
you know,
conversation wasn't that clear and make sure I go very,
I don't like written interviews to that reason.
Like I don't like it an article where it's just quoting that person.
Like let's see the,
let's see the video,
let's see how they came across.
Exactly.
My point about Anthony,
it goes back to my point about opie and Anthony getting across what he said on
Twitter with no humor without him,
without someone to talk to.
Also.
That's the other thing about Anthony's and weight plays off of people.
You know it have been a way better way to handle that.
Putting six,
you know,
who else got fucked that Adam Richmond man versus food guy show over.
Boom.
Very Mild,
very mild.
What he did,
He's talking about losing weight and he wrote something about like how much
weight it needs to lose.
And he wrote thin Spiration like Hashtag inspiration and he started getting
attacked by all these people that are apparently it's in the,
that's in the um,
uh,
Anorexia Movement,
this idea thins operation,
this Hashtag this.
And he didn't know about this,
so they started attacking him.
So see,
he starts responding to them,
attacking him.
He us one guy to fill a draw a bath and open your veins and,
and do the society.
Like that's it,
dude,
you're done.
And they pulled the show.
I actually liked that guy show a lot.
NBC.
I just signed him up for a new show.
That starts like next month though.
So he,
well he was on the travel channel pro.
They're rough.
They were rough with the Anthony Bordain.
They're rough with Bert Kreischer.
You know,
Burt [inaudible] allegedly since bird crash.
It doesn't smoke pot.
This is all fiction.
But if he did smoke pot,
he would have to do it off camera.
Right.
And hide it.
Right?
Yeah.
And uh,
Anthony Bourdain,
he had a problem with them too.
It was like,
I dunno,
I think they're,
they're quite conservative so they weren't happy.
But meanwhile,
homeboy,
he didn't handle it so well either white telling people to kill themselves
because they told you that thin inspiration is a,
uh,
an anorexia.
Yeah.
A hashtag.
By the way,
take it back.
Take,
take.
Say we're taking back fitspiration fuck the anorexic.
That's what he should say.
I think a lot of these people just need to have in the contract,
it's like,
look,
you're going to have a publicist that you have to send your tweets through if
you were paying you this much money.
Cause I know I even have almost said a few things and my girlfriend is a
publicist.
It's like,
don't say that.
What the fuck are you doing?
That's a standard thing.
Now with television shows,
a lot of people,
they uh,
in contracts,
they're asking for a control.
Your social media,
super,
super standard.
Like they want access.
They want to be able to tweet for you.
They want to be able to tweet things.
Right.
You know,
I've had terrible idea.
I've had that request.
Well I've had that request giving away your soul to somebody because really
that's,
that's what you have.
We're only gonna use it for promotional purposes and I'm,
I can't do that.
You can't say you're me like it tweets when I Youtube things people give me shit
about that already.
Like when all of our videos go up on youtube,
that's not me tweeting.
It's an automatic thing when you upload videos useful.
That's different from them.
It is.
But my point is even that it doesn't cost anything,
it's just a link to youtube.
People give me shit because it's not me.
They call it the Rogan Bot.
What would it should it be?
It should always be you,
but it should have a filter where they approve it and then once they have no
negative,
no,
no.
I mean it's,
it's almost instant.
Like,
like,
like every time you tweet it automatically gets sent to somebody.
Got,
yeah,
that's fine.
But based on,
based on like,
Hey,
you know,
if this tweet where to go out,
you had been fired from our
this job,
you can't get rid of them kind of power.
Especially a guy like Anthony especially,
you can't get around.
You can't get arrested then you can't lose a job from it is what I'm saying.
That's what that,
I mean if you're
Liz,
the two totally unrelated things,
what I'm saying is that he can't give them that and because the audience doesn't
want that.
One of the things that people love and that I love is that I know that we wrote
that con animal,
that's him.
It's a d right,
wrong,
bad,
good.
It's coming directly from him.
If I really think that somebody had a green light,
red light option,
whether or not his tweets got through,
that would be disgusting.
You know,
I would,
I don't want that.
I don't want anyone else involved in someone's tweets.
I just,
and giving them the,
like when when they asked me to do it,
they were like,
you know,
we're just going to promote promotional things.
And I was like,
how do I know what you're going to do?
Right?
And you're going to have access to,
you can do whatever you want.
You know,
you can delete my tweets if you don't like them.
Like what if I said something fucked up and I got on a plane?
They're like,
well we know you wanted to take that down.
Like what?
I wanted to take that down.
I didn't want to take that time.
I'm,
I'm meant that you can't have that.
No,
no.
That really is the only thing you have at the end of the day because uh,
like shows and networks change a lot,
especially for journalists.
But definitely for entertainers to all that stuff changes.
All you have is like your reputation with the public.
If they trashed that with a bunch of bullshit,
if these companies are not that smart,
like I see some companies on Twitter,
you're like,
this is it.
Don't fucking care about you.
They don't care about your vision.
Yeah,
we're out of time.
David Seaman.
Thanks again dude.
Fucking anytime,
man.
We've got to do this more often.
We,
uh,
the last one was only like,
what,
two months ago?
Yeah,
it was a month and a half or seven.
That's how we'll do it.
There's all this,
we're,
we're hitting this time.
We're change.
Things change so exponentially fast.
It seems so frantic and frenzy.
We need to as often as possible.
Goodbye everybody.
We'll see you soon.
Please support our sponsors.
Go to,
uh,
which one was this today was legal,
legal zoom.
Go to legal zoom.com.
Use the code word Rogan,
and also go to naturebox,
naturebox.com forward slash Rogen to get 50% off your months.
First box.
All right,
we'll see guys much love big cast.